THIS LABOR AND PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT
COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER A
GOOD AFTERNOON AS WE CONTINUE TO
TAKE SOME PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE
ONGOING CODE NINETEEN RHYS THE
SENATE CONTINUES TO WALK IN THE
PUBLIC HAS PROVIDED ACCESS. TO
BOTH THE IN PERSON UNTIL COVERS
PARTICIPATION FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND THEY'LL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN I'M%
GONNA ANNOUNCE THAT NUMBER NOW.
THE PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8163 AGAIN. 877-226-8163
THE ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN SIX
TWO. TWO FOUR SIX TWO AGAIN
SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR SIX TWO.
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. ROLLER
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE-
STREET BUILDING HI ASK ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. E
PRESENT IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED SO WE CAN GET STARTED-
WE WANT TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
WE DO HAVE A BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA- BEFORE WE HAVE
PRESENTATION THOSE BILLS- I'M
NOT GONNA ASK YOU TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE
ONE. NO POINT IN GOING THROUGH
THAT- LET ME JUST NOTE THAT SB
EIGHT THIRTY FIVE S. B. TEN
SIXTY FOUR SB ELEVEN SIXTY EIGHT
AND S. B. FORTINO TO- WILL BE
HEARD IN ONE MOTION ON CONSENT
WHO'S THE CONSENT ITEMS AND LET
ME ALSO INDICATE THAT. WHAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN THE THIRD ITEM
ON OUR AGENDA SB FOURTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT SENATOR LOANS BILL. HAS
BEEN- REMOVED FROM THE AGENDA
PULLED THAT THE AUTHORS REQUEST
SO THE BILL WILL NOT BE HEARD
TODAY. SENATOR BOOKER HERE YET
NO OKAY. HOPE YOU OF CENTER
BAKER IN A QUORUM SHORTLY SO
WILL PAUSE UNTIL THAT HAPPENS.
ZERO CENTER WHERE DO YOU MAY
PRESENT YOUR BILL IF YOU'RE
READY YOU WERE THE ONE AUTHORED
BESIDES MYSELF PRESENT. TO BE-
THE- SB NINE FIFTY SEVEN CENTER
WEIRD SENATOR WORDS BUILT ON
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS
BOARD SYRACUSE MISFORTUNES OF
DISTRICT. BOB WE'RE GOING TO.
CALLER QUORUM BEFORE THIS YEAH
WHEN WE CELLS QUORUM THANK YOU
CENTER ALERT FOR THE REMINDER
JUST IN CASE SOMEBODY WANT TO
VOTE ON THIS BILL. THAT'S A BIG
. CENTER COURTESY YOUR CENTER
COURTESY HERE OR CHOI BOGUE THE
RUSSELL THE RUSSELL HERE LATER
HERE THEY'RE HERE NEWMAN. SO
CORPS THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I'M HERE TO PRESENT US
SENATE BILL NINE FIFTY SEVEN IT
WOULD PLACE TO SANTA CRUZ
METROPOLITAN TRANSIT DISTRICT
ALSO KNOWN AS SANTA CRUZ METRO
UNDER THE JURISDICTION OF THE
PUBLIC EMPLOYEE RELATIONS BOARD
HERB- JUDICATA ALLEGED
COMPLAINTS OF LABOR VIOLATIONS
UNDER CURRENT LAW TO RESOLVE AN
ALLEGED CONFLICT BETWEEN THE
METRO AND ONE OF ITS EMPLOYEE OR
EMPLOYER ORGANIZATIONS A RICH
HAS TO BE FILED IN SUPERIOR
COURT. THIS PROCESS CAN BE TIME
CONSUMING EXPENSIVE AND NOT
NECESSARILY LEAD TO A FAIR
OUTCOME IN COMPARISON OF PURPOSE
AND ESTABLISHED AND TRUSTED
AGENCY THAT SPECIALIZES IN
PUBLIC EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE
CONFLICT RESOLUTION ARE MOVING
THE METRO UNDER THE JURISDICTION
OF HERBAL GIVE THEM AND THE
EMPLOYEES ACCESS TO A TIMELIER
AND MUCH MORE COST EFFECTIVE
PROCESS IT'S SUPPORTED BY
VARIOUS UNIONS- INCLUDING SEIU
AND SMART LOCAL TWENTY THREE
WHICH ARE BOTH A REPRESENT UNITS
AFTER METRO ENJOYS THE SUPPORT
OF THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS
A HANDFUL OF OTHER LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS. THERE IS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION I HAVE HAD
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE METRO
MANAGEMENT ABOUT THIS BILL AND
THEY'RE GOING TO CONSIDER THEIR
OFFICIAL POSITION DURING THE
SUMMER TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT R.
TERRY BRENNAN DIRECTOR OF-
REVENUE BUDGETED PENSIONS I'M
NOT TRIED KNEW HE HAD THAT TITLE
ADD UP S. CI YOU UP AND JAMES
SANDOVAL WHOSE AN ORGANIZER IN
THE GENERAL CHAIRPERSON FROM
SMART LOCAL A TWENTY THREE-
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. READ YOU
SENATOR SUBMITS BURNING GO FOR.
THE POLICE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN SENATORS TERRY BRENNAN
BEHALF OF S. YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA
AND WITH REGARD TO MY TITLE WE
JUST MAKE THEM UP INSTEAD GIVE
US PAY RAISES AND LABOR IT JUST
FOR THE RECORD YOU DON'T MAKE
THE FACTS UP IN YOUR TESTIMONY.
IS- JUST JUST MY TITLE JUST
CHECK- THIS IS AT LEAST THE
FIFTH AGENCY WE'VE INCLUDED
UNDER PERMANECE MANNER- WE'VE
USUALLY GOT AGREEMENT AS WE HAVE
IN THIS CASE BETWEEN MANAGEMENT
AND THE- WORKERS- SANTA CRUZ
MATTER WOULD JOIN- ORANGE
COUNTY. TRANSPORTATION LA METRO
PART IN SAC RT YOU'VE ALL GONE
THROUGH THIS PROCESS. NONE OF
THE PRIOR AGENCIES HAVE-
EXPERIENCED ANY ILL EFFECTS OF
GOING THIS WAY. THE ISSUES THAT
ARE BEFORE PER NEARLY DRAFTED
AND DO NOT INCLUDE WORK
STOPPAGES THINGS LIKE STRIKES
AND LOCKOUTS. WHERE YOU'D WANT
IMMEDIATE- COURT- RELIEF.
GRANDDAUGHTER GOING BEFORE THIS
BOARD IS THE SENATOR IN THE
STATEMENT. SURE STEP
PROFESSIONALS WHO DO THIS DAY IN
AND DAY OUT. REPEATEDLY ARE THE
ONES REVIEWING AT RATHER THAN-
RANDOM JUDICIAL OFFICERS WHO MAY
OR MAY NOT HAVE EXPERIENCE WITH.
LABOR IT IS LESS EXPENSIVE AND
MORE EFFICIENT AND PREFERRED
PRESERVES VALUABLE COURT TIME
FOR OTHER PURPOSES FOR THAT
REASON. WERE IN SUPPORT THANK
FOR MYSELF. OKAY THANK FOR
TESTIMONY JAMES SANDOVAL. IF
YOU'RE HERE YOU MAY SUPPORT A
PRESENT. THANK MR CHAIRMAN.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JAMES FEDERAL ON THE GENERAL
CHAIRPERSON OF SMART LOCAL
TWENTY THREE WHO REPRESENTS THE
BUS AND PARATRANSIT DRIVERS AT
SENATORS METRO. ON BEHALF OF
SMART LOCAL TWENTY THREE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL
SB NINE FIVE SEVEN. THIS BILL
BILL WILL REQUIRE EMPLOYERS
EMPLOYEES OF SANTA CRUZ
METROPOLITAN TRANSIT DISTRICT SB
MTG. TO EDUCATE COMPLAINTS OF
SPECIFIED LABOR VIOLATIONS
BEFORE THE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
RELATIONS BOARD PER. AS AN
UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICE CHARGE-
I'M UNLIKE OTHER CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC AGENCIES EMPLOYEES
TRANSIT IS LIKE S. E. N. T. AND
THEIR EMPLOYEES HAVE NO RECOURSE
TO THE PER. INSTEAD THEY MUST
RELY UPON THE COURTS TO REMEDY
ANY ALLEGED VIOLATIONS TO SETTLE
AN UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICE CHARGE
THESE DISTRICTS AND THEIR
EMPLOYEES MUST FILE A WRITTEN
SUPERIOR COURT WHICH COULD BE
VERY TIME CONSUMING AND VERY
EXPENSIVE FOR ALL PARTIES.
PURPOSE AN ESTABLISHED AND
TRUSTED AGENCY THAT SPECIALIZES
IN PUBLIC EMPLOYER. EMPLOYEE
CONFLICT RESOLUTION. MOVING
JURISDICTION OVER YOUR PIECE TO
PER WOULD ALLOW SEM TT PLOYS
THERE ARE TWO AXIS- A TIMELIER
AND MUCH MORE BUT MUCH MORE COST
EFFECTIVE PROCESS TO SETTLE
DISPUTES. AS WELL AS INCREASE
THE CONFIDENCE THAT DISPUTES
WILL BE ADJUDICATED BY BODY WITH
EXTENSIVE KNOWLEDGE OF LABOR LAW
THIS BILL SB NINE FIVE SEVEN
WILL NOT ESTABLISH NEW STATUTORY
COMPLY COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
FRAME BURKE WORKS. TMT SIMPLE.
PLACES MATTERS GOVERNING THE
RELATIONS UNDER THE- OF THE BIRD
. OR EASIER EDUCATION PROCESS
THE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS
BOARD LIKE THE NATIONAL LABOR
RELATIONS BOARD FOR ALL PRIVATE
SECTOR UNIONS WAS CREATED YEARS
AGO TO HELP IMPROVE THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN BETWEEN
EMPLOYERS AND THEIR EMPLOYEES.
MANY OTHER UNIONS AND EMPLOYERS
HAVE THIS VERY EFFECTIVE TOOL
AND WE'RE LOOKING TO HAVE IT AT
SENATORS MITCHELL TO. I THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU ALL BEFOREYOU
TODAY. WE WANT TO THANK. SENATOR
LAYERED FOR AND THE STAFF FOR
HELPING US BRING THIS MUCH
NEEDED LEGISLATION FOREIGN. AND
FOR ALL THE REASONS ABOVE AMONG
AMONG OTHERS OUR NATION STRONGLY
SUPPORTS IT I'M FIFTY FIVE SEVEN
EVERITT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IN
A VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY
THANKS FOR BEING HERE AND WE'RE
GOING TO ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. NINE FIFTY SEVEN. THANKS
MISTER EDUARDO MARTINEZ BUT THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU BUT ANYONE
ELSE WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT NAME AFFILIATION. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN ACOSTA SMART
TRANSPORTATION DIVISION STATE
LEGISLATIVE BOARD PROUD TO
SPONSOR SB NINE FIVE SEVEN
SUPPORT. HELLO I MONICA I- I'M A
PASSENGER FOR SANTA CRUZ TRANSIT
METRO AND I SUPPORT S. B. NINE
FIVE SEVEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO EXPRESS A
SUPPORT POSITION IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM- SEE NO ONE ELSE
STEPPED FORWARD WE'RE GONNA GO
TO THE MODERATOR S. MODERATOR TO
QUEUE UP. ANY SUPPORT WAS
WITNESSES ON SB NINE FIFTY SO.
EMLYON YEMEN IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
AGAINST SUPPORT FOR S. B. NINE
FIVE SEVEN THIS PRESS ONE ZERO.
ENSURE THE TIME WITH ABOUT SIX
IN OUR QUEUE OKAY IF WE CAN HEAR
THEM NOW THANK YOU. WE'LL START
WITH NUMBER TWENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMISSION GUSTIN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL. NEXT TO
THE NUMBER SEVENTEEN. HI MY NAME
IS TODD SKI- I'M A BUS OPERATOR
. SANTA CRUZ METRO SMART LOCAL
TWENTY THREE I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE FIVE SEVEN.
NEXT IS NUMBER THIRTEEN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M HOLLY ALCORN WITH
SEIU SB FIVE HUNDRED AND SPENT
CHRISTMAS SERVICE WHEN I ENTERED
OF THAT IT NINE FIVE SEVEN THANK
YOU. NUMBER. FOURTEEN THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN AND THE COMMITTEE- MY
NAME IS BONNIE MORE AND I AM-
PREVIOUS MEMBER AND EMPLOYEE
BENEFITS METRO TRANSIT DISTRICT
I WAS ALSO PARTICIPATED IN THE
STRIKE THAT TOOK PLACE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE I STRONGLY
SUPPORT- SB NINE FIFTY SEVEN AT
THIS TIME IN ORDER TO PRESERVE
LABOR HARMONY AS SORT. OF THE
CITY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. THE SOTO THIS PORTION
IS OF THE TESTIMONIES FOR NAME
AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT- OPPOSED
AND THIS IS THE SUPPORT SECTION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT TO THE
NUMBER SIXTEEN. THANK YOU- THIS
IS SURELY MARSHALL I SUPPORT THE
S. B. NINE FIVE SEVEN I AM A
TRANSIT BUS WRITER FOR SANTA
CRUZ. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO NUMBER THIRTY. BURKE
CANYON BIRD ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE
FIVE SEVEN THANK YOU. NEXT TO BE
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT. WILLIAM
O'CLOCK PLAN A POLITICAL
ORGANIZER WITH SEIU FIVE TWO ONE
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE FIVE SEVEN THANK YOU.
IMASSAGER THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE. OKAY THANK
YOU A MODERATE APPRECIATE THAT
WE HAVE NO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES LISTED FOR THIS BILL
YOUR ANYONE HERE IN THE ROOM WHO
WISHES TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION SB
NINE FIFTY SEVEN. SEEN NO INCOME
FOR LOCAL THE MODERATOR
MODERATOR BUT CAN YOU CHECK AND
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY. ON THE CALL IN LINE.
IN THE YEMEN THE PHONE LINES IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION. FIFTY NINE
FIVE SEVEN ONE ZERO. IN ONE ZERO
PROPOSITION. THIS IS YOUR THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE IN THE FIFTH
GRADE THANK YOU FOR CHECKING MY
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS HERE
PRESENT TO ON THE COMMITTEE SOME
OF WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
ALSO WE'RE GONNA COME BACK. TO
THE AUTHOR NANCY P. LIKE
OPPORTUNITY CLOSER OR ARE WE
JUST THANK EVERYBODY THAT
TESTIFIED I THINK IT MADE THE
CASE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
IPHONE OKAY IT WILL GO AHEAD IN-
CALL THE ROLL CALL AT THIS TIME.
CONSULTANT THANK YOU. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
COURTESY HI COURTESY I OR CHOI
BOGUE TO WRESTLE. THE RUSSELL I
LAYER BY LAYER I NEWMAN. OKAY SO
WE HAVE FOUR THREE AYE VOTES-
WILL PLACE THE BILL ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. I'M COMING BACK
TO. SENATOR BAKER I THOUGHT I
SOME COME IN. SENATE BILL. YOU
MAY PRESENT S. B. TWELVE FORTY
EIGHT IT FOR IF YOU'RE READY TO
GO. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS AND I HEY. AT THIS IN
HERE AS A- BASEBALL FAN.
PRESENTING SB TWELVE FORTY EIGHT
FOR THE MINOR LEAGUE BASEBALL
PLAYERS BILL OF RIGHTS IS THAT
BIPARTISAN MEASURE WHICH WILL
IMPROVE PLAYER TREATMENT BY THE
MAJOR LEAGUE. UNEMPLOYED WORKERS
FOR THE MOST MINOR LEAGUERS MAKE
LESS THAN TWELVE THOUSAND PER
YEAR. FOR THE TWENTY NINETEEN
SEASON MOB GROW REVENUE. YOUR
LARA LEFT BILLION THIS.
CONSECUTIVE YEAR OF. AND I
THOUSAND INCREASE SINCE SEVENTY
FIVE. BUT THE SAME PERIOD BY THE
PLAYERS IN CREE JUST SEVEN FIVE
PER OVER THE- FORTY FIVE YOU'RE
PURE- THE WORK CONDITIONS. OF MY
LEADERS HAVE BEEN WELL
DOCUMENTED. AND THESE THIS BILL
NOR THE PLAYERS ARE ASKING FOR
THAT MUCH ONLY LEVEL PLAYING
FIELD. FAIR TREATMENT AND DECENT
CONDITIONS. ADVANCE AGREE WHEN
ASKED ABOUT WHAT THEY WERE MOST
CONCERNED ABOUT OVER SEVENTY
FOUR PERCENT. OF FANS SAID MILEY
PLAYER TREATMENT AND
COMPENSATION. THIS BILL DOES A
FEW POINT THINGS FOCUS ON THE-
U. P. C. THE UNIFORM PLAYER
CONTRACTED ALL PLAYERS MUST SIGN
- INSTRUCTED BY THE OWNERS FIRST
IT DEFINES A MINOR LEAGUE
PLAYER. AND BE CLEAR PRIOR TO
THIS BILL THE SAID CALIFORNIA'S
ALWAYS CONSIDER BASEBALL PLAYER
EMPLOYEES REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. YEAH I
UNDERSTAND. THAT THIS FACT IS
NOT BEEN DISPUTED ONGOING
LITIGATION. THAT'S RIGHT
COMMITTED TO THE CHAIR. THAT WE
WILL AMEND THE BILL MOVING
FORWARD TO NOT COMMENT ON THIS
LITIGATION AROUND A PLEA
CLASSIFICATIONS WERE TAKING OUT
THAT PART OF THE BILL. OF
REMAINING SECONDLY IT REDUCES
THE MAXIMUM NUMBER OF YEARS A
PLAYER CAN BE ON CONTRACT BY THE
END OF YOUR OWNER'S. FROM SEVEN
YEARS TO FOUR YEARS. IF A PLAYER
AT THE END OF FOR YOUR PEER
WHAT'S DOWN IS FREE AGENT THEY
CAN DO SO. AT A LEVEL WAGE.
ALTERING THIS OVERLY RESTRICTIVE
CONTRACT WILL REDUCE THE TIME
SPENT RECEIVING. THE WAGES THAT
I MENTIONED EARLIER AND WE FOUR
YEARS IS MORE THAN ENOUGH TIME
TO EVALUATE PLAYER. THIRD PARTY
FROM THE GREAT WORK OF OUR
COLLEAGUE CENTER SKINNER
RELIGION NAME IMAGE AND LIKENESS
THIS BILL IS FOR THE PLAYERS WHO
WILL BE ABLE TO COME BE
COMPENSATED FOR OPPORTUNITIES. I
OUTSIDE RESPONSIBILITIES AS A
MINOR LEAGUE PLAYER FOR EXAMPLE.
OF THAT THE VIDEO GAME MLB THE
SHOW. IS SELLING FOR SEVEN
DOLLARS EACH EMPLOYERS HAVE NOT
SEEN. A PENNY FROM THAT. A THAT
WE ARE FOCUSED ON THIS ISSUE-
NOT ONE WORKER IN CALIFORNIA
SHOULD BE MISTREATED BY THEIR
EMPLOYERS AND- THE MOB IS NO
EXCEPTION. AS SO OFTEN THE CASE
CALIFORNIA CAN LEAD THE WAY HERE
WE STRONG SUPPORT FROM PLAYERS
FANS AT PLAYER ADVOCATES LABOR.
BUT IT'S NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE
FRANCE SMALL PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S AGREED THAT THE
STATUS QUO IN THIS SITUATION
CANNOT GO ON. ALSO A STATE THAT
WE HAD REGULAR CONTACT WITH MLB
TEAMS- AND EVERY MANY TIMES
BEFORE AND UNION STATION AROUND
FREE AGENCY EITHER RECEIVE WITH
THE SAVE AMERICA'S PASTIME ACT.
WE'RE YOU KNOW BASEBALL SAID
CERTAIN THINGS CAN'T BE DONE IT
ADDED. IF YOU KNOW WILL WILL
DESTROY THE LEAGUE IN AN NO WE
MANAGED TO KEEP GOING. UP WITH
TUMULTUOUS HISTORY. NOW WITH THE
TIME TO STEP UP AND DO WHAT'S
BEST FOR PLAYERS. AND REALLY AND
OUR BALL CLUBS. I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT IN LIGHT OF ONGOING
LITIGATION LET'S RECOGNIZING
MINOR LEAGUERS AS EMPLOYEES. I
WILL WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS AND OF
INDISCRETION WITH BOTH LABOR
ENTRY TO SRI COMMITTEES ON
AMENDMENTS- COMMITMENTS DURING
THIS BILL DOES NOT. IN THE WAY
OF ONGOING LITIGATION. AND
ACCEPT COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON THIS
LEGISLATION. EXPECT GRATITUDE TO
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION-
IT MY CO AUTHOR AN ASSEMBLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. FOOTBALL AND
HARD WORKING PLAYERS THAT SHOULD
NOT BE PUNISHED FOR TRYING TO
MAKE THEIR DREAMS COME TRUE.
WITH A NUMBER OF WITNESSES TO
TESTIFY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BAKER WILL GO
AHEAD IN- SIR CALLING UPON THE
WITNESSES AND- LET ME SEE I MAKE
IT CALLED OUT- BECAUSE OF-
COMPETING COMMITTEE ASSIGNMENTS
HERE AND I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
I APPRECIATE VERY MUCH YOUR-
YOUR STATEMENT- WITH REGARD TO.
FUTURE MEMBERS TO BE TAKEN- TO
BE CLEAR THERE'S NO MEMBERS ON
THE TABLE TODAY OR NOTHING
REALLY TO ACCEPT TODAY. PER SE-
BUT- BUT YOUR COMMITMENT THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO. TAKE A MEMBERS
GOING FORWARD- IN YOU KNOW PART
OF THE PROBLEM IS DOUBLE
REFERRAL DEADLINE REALLY DIDN'T
ALLOW US- A TO CREATE TIME IN A
TO TAKE THOSE- THOSE MEMBERS
HERE- MY UNDERSTANDING AND I
HEARD YOU SPEAK SPECIFICALLY TO
THE LITIGATION BUT I WANT TO SIT
IN IT IT IN- IN DIFFERENT WORDS.
BUT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
CLEAR. OF ONE IS TO REMOVE THE
BILL'S PROVISIONS FROM THE LABOR
CODE TO ADDRESS QUESTIONS ABOUT
SB TWELVE FORTY ITS AFFECT ON
CURRENT APPLICATION OF LABOR
PROTECTIONS. OF INTO IS TO
ENSURE THAT SB TWELVE FORTY
EIGHT SCOPE REMAINS LIMITED TO
MINOR LEAGUE EMPLOYMENT
CONTRACTS. LENGTH THE LENGTH OF
THOSE CONTRACTS AND GRANNY
PLAYERS MORE FLEXIBILITY RECEIVE
COMPENSATION FOR THE USE OF
THEIR INITIAL LIKENESS WITHIN
THOSE EMPLOYMENT CONTRACTS-
THOSE ARE WHAT OF OUR STAFF.
UNDERSTANDS AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS TIME TO BE- THE
MEMBERS THAT YOU WOULD BE
PROCEEDING WITH INTRODUCED REYES
IS THAT CORRECT YES THAT'S
CORRECT OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IN. AND OF COURSE THE CMMITTEE
RESERVES THE RIGHT TO REHEAR THE
BILL- IF THE THOSE WOMEN'S
HEART- COMPLETED. NOT THAT I
EXPECT THAT TO HAPPEN BUT I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S ON
THE RECORD- IN. TIME PERMITTING
AND A MAKE SOME OTHER COMMENTS
LATER AT I DIDN'T WANNA HAVE OF
PEOPLE CORNER HILLS HERE IN
TERMS OF TESTIMONY BUT I WANTED
TO BE SURE WHAT WAS HERE AS- THE
TEACHER THAT'S BEEN WORKING WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF TO MAKE SURE TO
GET THE RECORD STRAIGHT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER-
SO WE'RE GOING TO GO TO- LEAD
WITNESS- EDUARDO MARTINEZ THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE DO YOU
MIND MISTER MISTER PLEASE START
WITH THE- WHEN THIS ON THE
PHONE. THAT'S FINE THERE WILL
BE- TREVOR HILDENBERGER- YES
YEAH MISTER HOMER YOU CAN
PROCEED WE CAN I THINK WE CAN
HEAR YOU ALREADY- GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE. MY NAME IS TREVOR
HILDENBERGER I WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA
BEFORE BEING DRAFTED IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN HAVE UC
BERKELEY WHERE I JUST GRADUATED
. IT'S A COMMON MYTH THAT ALL
AND WILL BE DRAFTED A REWARDED
WITH HEFTY SIGNING BONUSES AND
BONUSES A MERE FIVE HUNDRED
SEVENTY ONE DOLLARS AFTER TAX.
THE MONTHLY RATE FOR YOUR FIRST
YEAR IS ONE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
DOLLARS. I CAME REQUIRED ALL
PLAYERS TO THE LOWEST LEVEL TO
LIVE IN THEIR TEAM PHONES
DORMITORY. THE DORMS ARE
SEVENTEEN DOLLARS A DAY TAKEN
OUT OF OUR PAYCHECKS AND AT THE
END OF EVERY TWO WEEKS MY PAY
STUB READ. ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
FIVE DOLLARS. DESPITE HAVING TO
TRAIN YEAR ROUND THESE TINY
PAYCHECKS STOP IN SEPTEMBER. I
FOUND A JOB AT A SPORTING GOODS
STORE IN ORDER TO FUND MY
TRADING AGAIN PLEASE CLEAT
BASEBALLS AND PROTEIN
SUPPLEMENTS. I STILL CAN AFFORD
RIGHT IN THE BAY AREA SO I MOVED
BACK IN WITH MY PARENTS A LUXURY
THAT NOT MANY PLAYERS HAVE.
FINDING AFFORDABLE SHORT TERM
HOUSING IS DIFFICULT FOR MANY OF
MY INTERNATIONAL TEAM MATES WHO
ARE YOUNG AND ENGLISH AS THEIR
SECOND LANGUAGE. LEADERS CAN BE
ESPECIALLY INTIMIDATING AND
TRICKY. SAVE ON COSTS IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN I LIVED ON A PULL OUT
COUCH IN A COCKROACH INFESTED
APARTMENT WHERE HE SAYS I'VE
BEEN ON WHICH SHIP THE BREAKER
AND ALL THE LIGHTS WILL GO OUT.
THE CHOICE IS SIMPLE MAKE DINNER
IN THE DARK OR EAT WENDY'S IN
THE LIGHT. AFTER THREE YEARS IN
THE MINORS OF LIVING PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK. WATCHING MY STUDENT
LOANS ACCRUE INTEREST FASTER
THAN I COULD PAY IT DOWN. AND
THEN LIKE A BURDEN ON MY PARENTS
AND GIRLFRIEND AT AGE TWENTY
SIX. I STARTED HAVING THAT
EFFECT. I LIVING MY CHILDHOOD
DREAM BUT IT FELT LIKE A
NIGHTMARE. BUT I REACH THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF THE MINOR
LEAGUES I WAS PAID TWENTY THREE
HUNDRED A MONTH. A COUPLE YEARS
LATER I WAS RELEASED INTO FREE
AGENCY AND A COMPETITIVE MARKET.
THE ABILITY TO SIGN WITH ANY
TEAM NOT JUST THE ONE ADOPTED
ME. AND I SIGNED A CONTRACT FOR
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND A MONTH.
FROM 230-022-9000 FOR THE SAME
JOB AT THE SAME LEVEL HOUSE
MAKING TWELVE AND A HALF TIMES
MORE. WE CAN FREE AGENCY AFTER
FOUR YEARS INSTEAD OF SEVEN
WOULD ALLOW PLAYERS TO BE FAIRLY
COMPENSATED THE TALENTS. AND WE
NEED SOME OF THE INCREDIBLE
STRAIN MINOR LEAGUE PLAYER THAT
FAMILIES HAVE OFFERED. THIS
REASON I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
TWELVE FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. I THINK YOUR
TESTIMONY AND NOW WILL COME BACK
TO COURT OVER TO THIS. AWESOME
THANKS MISTER EDUARDO MARTINEZ
FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FRAZIER
FEDERATION. APPRENTICE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE FORTY
EIGHT. I FOR ONE HUNDRED YEARS
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL IS TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF FEDERAL ANTI TRUST
EXEMPTIONS ALLOWING MLB OWNERS
TO COLLUDE ON MINOR LEAGUE
SALARIES IN A MANNER LIKE NO
OTHER MAJOR EMPLOYER. THIS
EXEMPTION HAS ALLOWED LEAGUE TO
PAY MOST MINOR LEAGUERS LESS
THAN TWELVE THOUSAND A YEAR. AND
FOR THE COMMITTEES REFERENCE AN
INDIVIDUAL CANNOT MEET BASIC
NEEDS ANYWHERE IN THE COUNTRY
EARNING LESS THAN TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND. THIS DISPARITIES
ESPECIALLY PROBLEMATIC FOR THE
NEARLY HALF OF MINOR LEAGUERS
WERE PEOPLE OF COLOR OR
IMMIGRANTS. WHO OFTEN DON'T HAVE
THE SOCIAL FAMILIAR NETWORK TO
LEAN ON. THERE'S SIMPLY NO
JUSTIFICATION FOR THIS TYPE OF
TREATMENT OF WORKERS OF ANY
TYPE. LET A LOAN FROM AN
INDUSTRY WITH RESOURCES SUCH AS
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL. R. S.
TWELVE FORTY WOULD GO A LONG WAY
TO CORRECTING THESE LONG
STANDING AND JUST AS- THAT MOST
ATHLETES INCLUDING RECENTLY
STUDENT ATHLETES CURRENTLY
ENJOY. IT IS PATIENT FROM
ARGUMENTS. FROM THE OPPOSITION
IF I COULD LEAVE YOU WITH A
QUOTE FROM A SPRING COURT
JUSTICE BRETT KAVANAUGH. WHO
RULED AGAINST NC DOUBLE A WHO
MADE SIMILAR ARGUMENTS ON THEIR
BUSINESS MODEL. QUOTE NO WHERE
ELSE IN AMERICA CAN BUSINESSES
GET AWAY WITH AGREE NOT TO PAY
THEIR WORKERS A FAIR MARKET
RATE. ON THE THEORY THAT THEIR
PRODUCT IS DEFINED BY NOT PAYING
THEIR WORKERS A FAIR MARKET
RATE. KEVIN KEVIN WENT ON TO SAY
THE NC DOUBLE A MODEL VERY
SIMILAR TO MLB'S. IS QUOTE
SUPPRESSING THE PAY OF STUDENT
ATHLETES WHO COLLECTIVELY
GENERATE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
REVENUES FOR COLLEGES. EVERY
YEAR. THOSE ENORMOUS SUMS OF
MONEY FLOW TO SEEMINGLY
EVERYONE. EXCEPT THE STUDENT
ATHLETES. BUT THE STUDENT
ATHLETES WHO GENERATE THE
REVENUES. MANY OF WHOM ARE
AFRICAN AMERICAN. AND LOWER
INCOME OF LOWER INCOME
BACKGROUNDS. END UP WITH LITTLE
OR NOTHING. WE COULD HAVE SAID
IT BETTER. YES WE ARE ABOUT.
THANKS FOR TESTIMONY. WAS THERE
ANYONE HERE THE COMMITTEE ROOM
WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS A SUPPORT
POSITION ON SB TWELVE FORTY
EIGHT IF SO PLEASE SUPPORT. A C.
NONE OF WILL GO TO THE MODERATOR
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY SUPPORT WITNESSES
ON SB TWELVE FORTY EIGHT. LET ME
KNOW THE NUMBER OF WITNESSES-
AND THEN YOU MAY PROCEED THANK
YOU. M. FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWELVE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT AN- AGAIN ONE
ZERO FOUR SUPPORT. TO SECURE THE
TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE IN Q.
THANK YOU FOR CHECKING- WE'RE
GONNA COME BACK NOW TO THE
OPPOSITION SIDE OF THE LEDGER
AND- WE DO HAVE TO READ
OPPOSITION WITNESSES LISTED ONE
OF SAN FERNANDO'S IN THE OTHERS
CHECK THEIR- SAMPRAS WHO WANNA
COME FORTH. POLICE- YOU MAY
PRESENT YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- ON BEHALF OF MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL IN THE MAJOR
LEAGUE CLUBS. I THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY- TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OPPOSITION OF- OF THE
SENATE BILL TWELVE FORTY EIGHT.
GIVEN CENTER BAKER'S COMMITMENT
TO WITHDRAW THE COMMENTS-
REGARDING THE- THE BILL'S IMPACT
ON THE CLASSIFICATION OF MINOR
LEAGUE PLAYERS IN CALIFORNIA I'M
NOT GOING TO DWELL ON THAT AS I
INTENDED TO. BUT I WILL
REMEMBER- REEMPHASIZED THE BILL
WITH THOSE COMMENTS HAS THE
DANGER OF IMPACTING EXIT-
CURRENT LITIGATION THAT HAS BEEN
ONGOING FOR EIGHT YEARS AND
DEALS WITH EXACTLY THE TYPES OF
ISSUES- THERE WOULD BE REYES. BY
THIS BILL. ONE OF THEM IS THAT-
THE TREATMENT OF MINOR LEAGUE
PLAYERS AS NON EXEMPT EMPLOYEES
IN CALIFORNIA WOULD BRING INTO
PLAY ALL SORTS OF- THINGS THAT.
TEAMS AND PLAYERS NORMALLY DO
NOT DO FOR EXAMPLE TAKING REST
BREAKS AND MEAL BREAKS DURING
THE COURSE OF THE GAME. THOSE
ARE JUST ONE OF THE VERY MANY-
THINGS THAT WOULD COME INTO PLAY
IF THIS BILL WERE. ENACTED TO
MAKE PLAYERS EXACT PLAYERS. I'M
GOING TO FOCUS ON THE N. I. L.
PROVISION- THIS BILL WOULD VOID
ANY PROVISION IN A MINOR LEAGUE
CONTRACT THAT COULD INTERFERE
WITH THE PLAYERS RIGHT. TO USE
THE PLAYER'S NAME IMAGE OR
LIKENESS ALSO KNOWN AS AND I ALL
RIGHT. THIS TOO IS UNNECESSARY
BECAUSE THERE IS NOTHING IN A
MINOR LEAGUE CONTRACT. I WAS A
PLAYER OF HIS AND I ALL RIGHT.
FOR A MINOR LEAGUE CONTRACT
GRANT EACH PLAYER'S CLUB THE
RIGHTS THAT IT NEEDS IN ORDER TO
PROMOTE THE TEAM AND THE PLAYER.
THE CONTRACT ALSO GRANTS THE
CLUB THE RIGHT TO REVIEW AND
APPROVE OF PLAYERS USE OF HIS
AND I ALL RIGHT. THIS APPROVAL
PROCESS IS NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT
A PLAYER WILL NOT AUTHORIZE THE
USE OF THESE RIGHTS IN
CONNECTION WITH THE PRODUCT
GROUP OR ACTIVITY. THAT COULD BE
EMBARRASSING OR DETRIMENTAL TO
THE PLAYER OR THE CLUB. THAT'S
WHY EVEN MAJOR LEAGUE PLAYERS
HAVE AGREED IN COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING THE CLUB SHOULD HAVE
A RIGHT TO REVIEW AND APPROVE
APPROVE A PLAYER'S USE OF THEIR-
RIGHTS FOR THE REASON I'VE
DECIDED- WE OPPOSE SENATE BILL
TWELVE FORTY EIGHT. NOW I'D LIKE
TO TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
JACK THERE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SAM MY NAME IS JACK PAYER-
EXECUTIVE PRESIDENT OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO GIANTS. AND I'M GONNA
FOCUS ON THE FOR YOUR NATURE OF
THE CONTRACT PROPOSAL- OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S A LOT. OF COMPLEXITIES
TO THIS LITIGATION- TO THIS THIS
LEGISLATION AND THERE'S- THEY'RE
BEING PLAYED OUT IN LITIGATION
RIGHT NOW WITH RESPECT TO MILEY
COMPENSATION AND BENEFITS- SO.
THE ISSUE OF MOVING FROM A SEVEN
TO A FOUR YEAR CONTRACT. THIS
PROVISION WOULD BE VERY HARMFUL
TO CALIFORNIA BASED CLUBS A
CALIFORNIA BASED PLAYERS IN MANY
RESPECTS. IT CREATES A DIFFERENT
SET OF RULES ARE FOR CALIFORNIA
BASED CLUBS AND FOR CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS AND FOR OF PLAYERS
THAT PLAY FOR CALIFORNIA TEAMS.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO OPERATE A
LEAGUE WITH DIFFERENT RULES OF
ENGAGEMENT. BETWEEN THE
DIFFERENT CLUBS. FOR EXAMPLE OF
A SEVEN YEAR CONTRACT VERSUS
FOUR YEAR CONTRACT MANY MINOR
LEAGUE PLAYERS DO NOT MAKE THE
MAJOR LEAGUES WITHIN THE FOUR
YEAR TIME FRAME. THIS IS
PARTICULARLY TRUE WITH PLAYERS
THAT ARE INTERNATIONAL OF THE
CHOSEN FROM AN EARLY
INTERNATIONAL LOCATIONS OR HAVE
NOT ATTENDED COLLEGE IN UNITED
STATES WHERE IT'S CUSTOMARY FOR
PLAYERS TO SPEND MORE THAN FOUR
YEARS IN THE MINOR LEAGUE SYSTEM
BEFORE THEY MAKE THE MAJORS. AND
SO IF YOU'RE A CALIFORNIA BASED
CLUB. AND YOU'RE TRYING TO
RECRUIT PLAYERS. IT'S A HUGE
DISADVANTAGE BECAUSE. LIKELY NOT
TO MAKE THE MAJORS WITHIN FOUR
YEARS MEANS THAT YOU WOULD
PROBABLY FOCUS YOUR ENERGIES ON
SIGNING COLLEGE PLAYERS WERE
MORE LIKELY TO MAKE THE MAJORS
WITHIN THE FOUR YEAR TIME FRAME
AND THEREFORE CALIFORNIA BASED
OF PLAYERS WHO DO NOT HAVE
COLLEGE BASEBALL EXPERIENCE WILL
BE GREATLY DISADVANTAGED BECAUSE
NO CLUB WANT TO SIGN THAT PLAYER
TO A FOUR YEAR CONTRACT KNOWING
THAT THERE IS NOT LIKELY TO MAKE
THE MAJORS WITHIN FOUR YEARS.
LIKE WAYS CALIFORNIA CLOSE WOULD
NOT WANT TO SIGN FOREIGN BORN
PLAYERS- FROM THE DOMINICAN
REPUBLIC AND OTHER LOCATIONS AT
AGE SEVENTEEN WHICH IS THE
CURRENT RULES- KNOWING THAT THEY
ARE UNLIKELY TO MAKE THE MAJORS-
IN TIME AS WELL. IF YOU'RE A
CALIFORNIA BASED PLAYER AND YOU
CAN ONLY SIGN A FOUR YEAR
CONTRACT OTHER TEAMS OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE GOING TO BE
RELUCTANT TO SIGN YOU AS WELL
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT SURE WHETHER
YOU'LL MAKE IT WITHIN FOUR YEARS
AND YOUR SIGNING BONUSES WILL BE
AFFECTED- RIGHT NOW THE AVERAGE
MAJOR LEAGUE MEMBERS MINOR
LEAGUE PLAYER HAS A SIGNING
BONUS OF THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
FOUR THOUSAND. DOLLARS WHEN THEY
SIGN THEIR INITIAL CONTRACT WITH
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL- AND THAT
DOLLARS CAN BE AFFECTED BY. THE
LENGTH OF THE CONTRACT. AND WITH
RESPECT TO A CALIFORNIA CLUB WE
WANT TO BE COMPETITIVE WITH OUR
TEAMS FROM OTHER STATES. WANT TO
PUT A WINNING TEAM ON THE FIELD.
AND IF WE CAN ONLY SIGN COLLEGE
PLAYERS. THEN THE 40% OF THE
MINOR LEAGUE PLAYERS THAT ARE
FOREIGN BORN. AND MANY PLAYERS
WHO PLAYED IN HIGH SCHOOL AND
DON'T PLAYING COLLEGE WOULD BE
SOMEWHAT OFF LIMITS TO US AT
THAT WE CAN'T. BE SURE THAT THEY
COULD MAKE IT IN TIME AND SO WE
WOULD BE SIGNING FROM A LIMITED
POOL PLAYERS IN CALIFORNIA
PUTTING IT IS ALSO A HUGE
COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE. IS VIA
THE OTHER TEAMS AND THE
CALIFORNIA'S PLAYERS WERE ALSO
PIECE THAT DISADVANTAGE IN THAT
THEY WOULD BE LESS MARKETABLE.
AND FINALLY WE WOULD BE HAVING A
VERY DIFFICULT TIME TRADING A
PLAYER- THAT'S A MINOR LEAGUE
PLAYER WHICH HAPPENS ALL THE
TIME. IF THEY HAVE A LIMITED
CONTRACT LEFT- BECAUSE THAT
PLAYER WOULD BE OF LESS VALUE
THAN A PLAYER. FOR US OF THAT
PLACE ROUTINE OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH HAS A LONGER
CONTRACT LENGTH. THE TO SUM UP
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS IN LITIGATION
THIS IS COMPLICATED- AND WE
BELIEVE THAT- THAT PROCESS
SHOULD BE RESPECTED. AND I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS IN THAT REGARD. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MISTER BEAR- WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION OF
TWELVE FORTY EIGHT. HELLO MY
NAME IS OSCAR SORIA KNOWN AS A
COLLEGE STUDENT ATHLETE I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SEEN NO OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO IT SB
TWELVE FORTY EIGHT WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS. MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE FROM THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF SB TWELVE FORTY EIGHT WILL BE
CAN'T. ANALYST JOHN ON THE PHONE
LINE IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SP TWELVE
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. AT THE TIME WE HAVE
NO ONE IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BETTER IF YOU WOULD PLEASE CHECK
LINES ONE MORE TIME JUST TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
TWELVE FORTY EIGHT. ABSOLUTELY
ONCE AGAIN IN OPPOSITION TO I'M
SB TWELVE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. IN ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYONE IN OUR QUEUE
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR IF YOU-
AND THANK YOU TO ALL OUR SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION WITNESSES HERE
TODAY WILL NOT BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO OUR MEMBERS
TO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. I HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS. I'M AS MUCH AS I
ADORE AND LOVE BASEBALL
OBVIOUSLY I DON'T KNOW ALL THE
RULES AND ALL THE DYNAMICS THAT
HAPPEN ALL THE TIME I JUST LIKE
TO GO TO THE STADIUM AND CHEER
FOR MY TEAM IN. LOS ANGELES- BUT
I DO HAVE YOU KNOW SOME
QUESTIONS BECAUSE OF THAT IT
DOES HAVE SOME REAL BASIC
QUESTIONS. ON ON THE LITIGATION
THAT'S BEEN REFERRED TO. FROM
DOES THE LITIGATION COVER ALL OF
THE ISSUES. THAT ARE IN PLAY
HERE- WITH THIS LEGISLATION OR
WAS IT JUST ON THE ISSUE OF- ON
EMPLOYEE STATUS OR LABOR. CODE
YES THE LITIGATION IS JUST ON
THE EMPLOYEE STATUS IN THE
COMPENSATION PIECE THAT'S OR
TAKING THAT PART OUT IT DOESN'T
REFER TO THE LENGTH OF THE
CONTRACT OR THE AND I L. PORTION
. OKAY SO DOES THAT MEAN THAT.
WE'RE TAKING THAT. THE READING
THAT PART OF IT OUT BUT WE'RE
KEEPING IN THE LENGTH OF THE
CONTRACT. AND THE AND I'LL- OKAY
OKAY BECAUSE I THAT WAS RAISED
BY. YEAH THE OPPOSITION SO THE
LITIGATION ISSUE IS NOT AN ISSUE
ANYMORE YES WE'VE COMMITTED TO
IF YOU'RE- YEAH IF THAT WORKS
OUT YEAH- THE SECOND THING IS
IF. I'M I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
THE FOUR YEAR AND THE LENGTH OF
THE CONTRACT THE FOUR YEAR AND
THE SEVENTH YEAR- SOME REFERENCE
WAS MADE BY MR. BEAR AS TO THE
DISADVANTAGES TO OF FOREIGN BORN
AND HIGH SCHOOL- I GUESS HIGH
SCHOOL- PLAYERS ARE RECENTLY
GRADUATED HIGH SCHOOL PLAYERS-
WHAT WHY IS THAT. A DISADVANTAGE
FOR THOSE GROUPS AND THEY- ADD
UP 240% YEAH THE LEGISLATURE
PRINTERS REALLY TO THIS FINISH
TO TEAMS IN RECRUITING THOSE
PLAYERS. BECAUSE THEY'RE OFTEN-
HI YOU KNOW AT A YOUNGER AGE
RIGHT YOU MIGHT HAVE A HIGH
SCHOOLER WHO'S YOU KNOW
SEVENTEEN OR EIGHTEEN OR A KID
FOR ANOTHER COUNTRY WHOSE THAT
AGE. AND THEREFORE THEY'RE
SAYING. THAT YOU KNOW FOR YEARSIS NOT ENOUGH TO EVALUATE SOME
OF THAT YOUNG WHEREAS AGAIN
WOULD AGREE SOMEONE COMING OUT
OF COLLEGE- FOUR YEARS IS
PROBABLY AN APPROPRIATE TIME AT
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO SO I DON'T
THINK HE'S SAYING THAT IT'S A
DISADVANTAGE TO. THOSE FOREIGN
BORN PLAYERS HE'S I THINK THAT
THE ARGUMENT IS FOR CHARACTERIZE
IT THE ARGUMENT IS THAT IT'S A
DISTURBING CALIFORNIA TEAMS-
BECAUSE- THEY- THEY WOULD ONLY
HAVE FOUR YEARS TO EVALUATE
THOSE PLAYERS THAT THEY SIGNED A
YOUNG AGE WHERE'S OTHER TEAMS
WOULD HAVE. SEVEN YEARS TO- BUT
I'LL WAIT AT AT A- THOSE TEAMS A
YOUNGER AGE AND I GUESS JUST TO
CUT TO THE CHASE I MEAN OUR OUR
POSITION ON THAT. ISSUE IS JUST
THAT- A WITCH THING IF FORTY WE
WEEKLY FOR YEARS IS LONG ENOUGH
TO EVALUATE A PLAYER I CERTAINLY
PARTICULARLY THOSE YOU KNOW
COLLEGE COMING OUT OF COLLEGE
BUT WE LEAVE IN GENERAL FOR
YEARS IS LONG ENOUGH. AND. THEY
CAN THEN ARE WE SIGN. THIS TO
INTO COST. AND THERE ARE EVEN
OTHER LEAKS THAT HAVE A RIGHT OF
FIRST REFUSAL YOU CAN EVEN PUT
IN SAY RIGHT FIRST REFUSAL. SAID
IF SOMEBODY OFFERS- THAT PLAYER
A BIG SALARY YOU CAN STILL MATCH
IT AND RETAIN THEIR RIGHTS. SO
NOBODY SAYING YOU CAN STILL SIGN
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS BUT AFTER
WERE YOU MEAN THROUGH ANOTHER
THREE YEARS. BUT AFTER FOUR
YEARS THEY WOULD THEN BE A FREE
AGENT- JUST AS THE OUR AS OUR
WITNESS WAS A FREE AGENT AFTER
SEVEN YEARS AS A OF A SIGN OF
MUCH. BETTER CONTRACT WHILE
STILL- BUT STILL OCCUPY THE SAME
ROLE IN THE MINOR LEAGUES. SO
OUR CONTRACTS. EXACTLY FOR SEVEN
YEARS OR IS IT UP TO SEVEN
YEARS. GOING TO BE LESS THAN
SEVEN YEARS IN TERMS OF WHAT'S
ACTUALLY. SIGNERS EVERYONE OKAY
SO IF YOU IF YOU WANT TO. GO
AHEAD SPEAKER. I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY ONE POINT AND IT'S NOT
ONLY DISADVANTAGE TO THE CLUBS.
WHO WOULD ONLY BE ABLE TO SIGN
PLAYERS FOR FOUR YEARS AND
THEREFORE MIGHT NOT WANT TO
INVEST IN A PLAYER THAT MIGHT
NOT MAKE IT WITHIN FOUR YEARS-
OF FOREIGN BORN PLAYER I SCHOOL
PLAYER. BUT IT'S ALSO A
DISADVANTAGE TO THOSE PLAYERS
THEMSELVES. WHO CAN ONLY SIGN A
FOUR YEAR CONTRACT SO. IF YOU'RE
THE ARIZONA DIAMONDBACKS OR THE
NEW YORK YANKEES. AND YOU HAVE A
CHOICE BETWEEN A PLAYER THAT YOU
CAN SIGN FOR SEVEN YEARS OR
PLAYER YOU COULD ONLY SIGN FOR
FOUR YEARS. YOU'RE GONNA CHOOSE
THE PLAYER THAT YOU CAN SIGN FOR
SEVEN YEARS SO THE PLAYERS WILL
HAVE LESS OPPORTUNITY IF THEY
COME FROM CALIFORNIA. THAN THEY
WOULD IF THEY CAME FROM OTHER
STATES. SO THIS WOULD
DISADVANTAGED BUT ONLY THE
CLUB'S ABILITY TO COMPETE WIH
TEAMS OUT OF CALIFORNIA. BUT ALL
THE PLAYERS WHO STAND TO BE
SIGNED. THAT LIVE IN CALIFORNIA
WHO WANT TO PLAY PROFESSIONAL
BASEBALL WILL BE A DISADVANTAGED
BECAUSE. OF THE OLDER PEERS FROM
OTHER STATES. THE I WANT TO GIVE
IT TO QUIT. OBVIOUSLY WE BELIEVE
THAT BUT NOW BE THE CASE OF A-
AT PLAYER HAS PROMISED AND THEY
HAVE FOR YEARS- TO LOCK THEM UP
IN MAYBE A RIGHT. OF REFUSAL
AFTER THAT- WE THINK TEAMS WOULD
STILL GO AHEAD SIGNED THOSE
PLAYERS. THE PROBLEM IS THAT 40%
OF THE MINOR. LEAGUE PLAYERS.
ARE FOREIGN BORN KEPT LIQUOR.
SORRY THAT'S OKAY MISTER BERRY
ANDERSON. MOST OF US ARE VERY
NEW TO THE AREA TO THEIR OF.
RULES AND REGULATIONS HERE AND
IN THE COMMITTEE- BUT GIVE ME
ONE SECOND- SENATOR- DOORS IF
YOU HAVE ANY OTHER. QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS. WELL I WAS TRYING TO
GET CLARITY I'M SORRY. I WAS AND
I MEAN TO. TAKE OVER THE
CONVERSATION HERE BUT- JUST TO
GET CLARITY AS TO. WHO'S
DISADVANTAGED AND WIDER
DISADVANTAGING HOW THE FOUR YEAR
AND SEVEN YEAR. FIT INTO THAT-
THAT'S THE THAT'S THE MAIN.
QUESTION BECAUSE- OBVIOUSLY WE
DON'T WANT A DISADVANTAGE OF
PLAYERS. A WE WANT TO. GIVE THEM
THE MOST LEVERAGE THEY CAN USE
BASED ON THEIR SKILLS. WE WANT
THEM TO GET THE BEST DEAL WE
WANT THEM TO. SOONER THAN LATER
RIGHT- MAKE MORE MONEY- AS WELL
AS LOVE THEIR- CAREER. SOME I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THIS. SO IT
IS RIGHT NOW MAKE YOUR THE
CONTENTION OF. THIS BILL AND-
THE ALL THE SUPPORTERS OF THIS
BILL. THAT MAKING A HAVING A
FOUR YEAR CONTRACT RATHER SEVEN
WOULD GIVE THAT LEVERAGE RIGHT
TO THINK ABOUT THE WITNESS WHO
TESTIFIED- THAT WAS. YOU KNOW WE
HAD TO WAIT TILL AFTER SEVEN
YEARS- THAN DOING PERFORMING THE
SAME JOB. TO GET A TWELVE TIMES
HIGHER SALARY. AND SO PRESUMABLY
AFTER FOUR YEARS- THAT. ARE FOR
A WITNESS- WOULD BE A MINOR
LEAGUE FREE AGENT. COULD HAVE
GOTTEN A MUCH HIGHER SALARY AT
THAT TIME. YEAH SO I THINK YOU
KNOW A CLEARLY- I MEAN WHOLE
PREMISE OF FREE AGENCY IS THAT.
RIGHT IS THAT IT'S IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF PLAYERS TO HAVE
THAT ABILITY TO GO AND
NEGOTIATE. AND THAT'S REALLY
THAT THE PREMISE I DON'T YOU
KNOW THAT THE CONTENTION IS
THAT. THAT WOULD MAKE YOU- TEAM
LESS LIKELY TO SIGN A YOUNG
PLAYERBECAUSE THEY ONLY HAVE
BEEN FOR FOUR YEARS AND IF THEY
MIGHT NOT SIGN THEM. AND I THINK
THE REALITY IS WE HAVE TO
BELIEVE THAT. YOU KNOW PLAYERS
WITH PROMISES ARE GOING TO GET
SIDE- AND FOR YOU TO GET THERE
YOU FOUR YEARS TO VALUATE AND
AFTER THAT. YOU CAN STILL SIGN
THEM YOU KNOW IT IN UNDER OF OUR
BILL PASSES YOU FOR YEARS TO
EVALUATE. AND IF THE GREAT AND
YOU WANT TO SIGN OF LONGER THAN
YOU CAN SIGN LONGER. RIGHT AND
AGAIN MOB COULD EVEN PUT A
PROVISION THAT YOU HAVE THE
RIGHT OF FIRST REFUSAL SOMEBODY
ELSE OFFERS THEM A MUCH BIGGER
DEAL YOU CAN MATCH THAT- AND-
AND WHY BEING. I'M SORRY TO
SWIM. WHY BEING FOREIGN BORN WHY
IS THAT A DISADVANTAGE- I DON'T
THINK IT'S RIDICULOUS IS
VANISHING THE SCOUTING AND- IN
THESE COUNTRIES IS QUITE
ADVANCED AND DEVELOPED AGAIN I
THINK THE CONTENTION WOULD BE IF
YOU ONLY FOUR YEARS YO'RE GOT
WE ARE LESS LIKELY TO SIGN. A
FORM FOR YOUNGER PEOPLE YOU KNOW
GENERALLY YOUNGER PLAYER THAN
YOU WOULD SAY A KID COMING OUT
OF COLLEGE IN THE US THAT'S THE
CONTENTION YOU KNOW. BECAUSE
THEY'VE ALREADY SHOWN THE KID
OUT OF COLLEGE IS ALREADY SHOWN
. BOB DOLE OR WOULD. YOU TO GET
TO IT JUST BECAUSE YOU CAN- YEAH
THAT THEY'RE OLDER AND YOU'VE
MORE YOU KNOW MORE. A MORE BODY
WORK TO EVALUATE THEM ON. SO THE
CONTENTION WOULD BE THAT. YOU
pLIKELY TO SIGN SOMEONE- THE
FOREIGN BORN PLAYER. THAT YOU
YOU KNOW IF YOU HAVE LESS TIME
TO EVALUATE. THE SENATE ADDRESS-
WOULD BE HELPFUL TO HEAR FROM
THE- FROM THE WEST WITNESS. MR
WHERE WOULD YOU LIKE TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND YES-
FOREIGN BORN PLAYERS ARE SIGNED
AND START PLAYING AT AGE
SEVENTEEN. THEY TYPICALLY PLAY
THREE YEARS OVERSEAS- IN THE
ACADEMIES IN THE DOMINICAN
REPUBLIC- AND THEN THEY
MATRICULATED UNITED STATES AND
THEY BEGIN THEIR CAREER IN
UNITED STATES AND SO IT'S VERY
RARE FOR A FOREIGN BORN PLAYER
TO MAKE THE MAJORS WITHIN FOUR
YEARS. SO THE ISSUE IS IF YOU'RE
UNLIKELY TO GET THE BENEFIT OF
THE PLAYER MAKING THE MAJORS
WITHIN FOUR YEARS WOULD YOU SIGN
INVEST IN THAT PLAYER. ARMED AND
ALL OTHER TEAMS OUTSIDE
CALIFORNIA THE TWENTY FIVE OTHER
MAJOR LEAGUE CLUBS WOULD HAVE
THE ABILITY TO SIGN A PLAYER FOR
SEVEN YEARS AND THEREFORE
THEY'RE GOING TO SIGN PLAYERS
THAT ARE FOREIGN BORN AT A
HIGHER CLIP THAN WE WOULD. AND
WITH 40% OF THE MINOR LEAGUERS
BEING FOREIGN BORN IF WE CANNOT
COMPETE IN THAT MARKETPLACE
CALIFORNIA CLUBS ARE EXTREMELY
DISADVANTAGED. WELL I I'D HAVE
TO LOOK TO SEE HOW MANY YEARS HE
PLAYED IN THE MINORS. SENATOR
ALSO THE CENTENARY. HELLO ARE
YOU OK YES SHE SAID GO AHEAD
SAID EARLIER THANK YOU I'M GONNA
FOLLOW UP ON THIS WAS BOTH OF
YOU WITH THE QUESTION IT AND
FIRST CAN I JUST ASK YOU KNOW
THESE AMENDMENTS DROPPED OUT OF
THE SKY TODAY SO WHAT ME BE
REALLY CLEAR IT TAKES EVERYTHING
OUT OF YOUR BILL BUT THE
CONTRACT LENGTH AND- THE NAME
IMAGE AND LIKENESS THOSE ARE THE
ONLY TWO THINGS LEFT IN THE BILL
YEAH. OKAY THE END I WANNA
CONTINUE THE QUESTIONING FROM
CENTER DRAWS BECAUSE USE YOUR
PRESUMPTION IS THAT IF
SOMEBODY'S CONTRACT AND SAID FOR
YEARS THAN THEIR NEGOTIATING
FROM STRENGTH THAT THAT WAS THE
PRESUMPTION. WHAT WHY IS THAT
THE PRESUMPTION. WELL CURRENTLY
IF THEY DON'T WANT THE TEAM
DOESN'T WANT THAT PLAYER WILL
JUST CUT THEM RIGHT SO THAT THE
OF THE WHOLE PREMISE IS THAT
AFTER FOUR YEARS THAT YOU ARE
YOU SEEN AS HAVING PROMISED
SOMEWHERE YOU'RE NOT SEEN
HOUSING PROMISE SOMEWHERE THE
PLAN I CAN KEEP YOU AROUND
ANYWAY IF YOU ARE SEEN AS HAVING
PROMISED SOMEWHERE THEN SOMEBODY
COULD SIGN BUT IT FORCES THAT
ISSUE IN A WAY THAT. SOMEBODY
COULD CONTINUE PLAYING UP UNTIL
SEVEN YEARS AND NOT HAVE THE
ISSUE FORCED AND MAKE IT AND
THIS FORCES A TEAM TO DECIDE
AFTER FOR WHEN THEY MIGHT STILL
HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO DO IT.
RIGHT I DON'T. NO I THINK IF THE
CONTENTIOUS SOMEHOW THIS HARMS
PLAYERS BECAUSE- THEY HAVE A
RIGHT FOR YEARS. I JUST DON'T
THINK IF YOU IF YOU THINK ABOUT
IT I JUST DON'T THINK THAT-
CONTENTION HOLDS UP. WELL LET ME
ASK- MISTER BEAR BECAUSE
SOMEBODY TOLD ME THE NAME OF%
SOMEBODY THAT FITS THIS AND SO I
NEED SOMEBODY YOU WOULD KNOW. SO
IF PUBLISHED SUNDAY VALL. CAME
UP TO THE MAJORS. AFTER FOUR
YEARS WHICH I THINK HE WAS IN
THE MINORS FOR LONGER THAN THAT
HOW WOULD HE FIT IN THIS
DISCUSSION WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
WELL UNDER UNDER THIS SITUATION
THE GIANTS WOULD BE RELUCTANT TO
SIGN HIM IN THE FIRST PLACE TO A
FOUR YEAR CONTRACT BECAUSE HE
WAS A SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD PLAYER
INTERNATIONALLY. AND HE DIDN'T
MAKE IT TO THE MAJORS HE SIGNED
IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWO WE MADE
THE MAJORS IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT. SO AFTER FOUR YEARS THEN
HE WOULD A FREE AGENT AT ANY
TIME ANY TEAM COULD SIGN HIM. US
WE'D BE COMPETING AGAINST THE
TWENTY NINE OTHER CLUBS. OF FOR
HIS SERVICES SO. YOU KNOW IN
THAT SITUATION. PUBLIC SANDOVAL
MIGHT IT NOT HAVE BEEN A GIANT
IF THIS LEGISLATION PASSES WOOD.
THE- THE OTHER PIECES IS WOULD.
YOU WITH WHAT YOU KNOW ABOUT HIM
WOULD HE HAVE THE LEVERAGE TO
HAVE CONTINUED AFTER FOUR YEARS
C. BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO ME. THIS
MOVES AHEAD AND SETS A MORE
ARBITRARY THING. AND I HAVEN'T
DETERMINED THAT THAT'S TO THE
ADVANTAGE OF THE PLAYERS THAT
I'M TRYING TO GET AT THAT WITH
THIS. I MEAN YOU'RE SAYING THAT
IT'S QUITE POSSIBLE HE NEVER
WOULD HAVE BEEN SIGNED IN THE
FIRST PLACE FOR THE MINERS THIS
IS THAT YOUR CONTENTION. RIGHT
MY CONTENTION WOULD BE THAT HE
WOULD BEEN SIGNED BY TEAM
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA TO A SEVEN
YEAR CONTRACT WHICH FITS THE
DEVELOPMENT CYCLE BETTER FOR AN
INTERNATIONAL PLAYER. OF IF
FORCED TO SIGN A PLAYER FOR A
FOUR YEAR CONTRACT. IT MAKES IT
HARDER TO SIGN INTERNATIONAL
PLAYERS. AND DEPENDING ON WHERE
THAT PLAYER IS AT THE END OF
FOUR YEARS. WHETHER THEY'RE A
PROSPECT OR NOT THEY MAY WELL BE
A PROSPECT. THEY WOULD HAVE THE
ABILITY TO GO SIGN WITH ANOTHER
TEAM. AND NOT. THE GIANTS IN A
RELATED GEN I THOUGHT YOU MIGHT
BE BETTER CITY. TO THE- HIS ROOM
IF W HAVE DIFFERENT ROLES FOR
CALIFORNIA AND THE OTHER FORTY
NINE STATES. IS THERE PRESSURE
ANOTHER TEAMS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF CALIFORNIA'S RULES IF THEY'RE
DEFERRED AND DISADVANTAGED
EITHER PLAYERS OR TEAMS AND IF
BECAUSE- ORIGINALLY. WHEN I READ
THE ANNOUNCES THAT SAYS ANY THIS
APPLIES TO ANY TEAM THAT PLAYS
IN CALIFORNIA AND SO. THIS WOULD
APPLY TO ANY TEAM FROM ANOTHER
STATE JUST PLAY HERE RIGHT IS
THAT CORRECT THEM. BECAUSE THE
THAT SAID THAT SOMEWHERE IN THE
ANALYSIS- I THINK THAT WAS
PRETTY MORE TOWARDS THE A
COMPENSATION OF PIECES SO IN
TERMS OF THE CONTRACT IT WOULD
BE- THERE'S LIVING HERE TEAMS
BASED HERE. THANKS I WAS TRYING
TO DETERMINE IF THIS
DISADVANTAGES CALIFORNIA. WELL I
THINK CERTAINLY THAT CONTENTION
WOULD BE YEAH THAT THAT WAS THE
CONTENTION MADE- AND I THINK YOU
KNOW IT'S A SITUATION WHERE WE
REALLY HAVE TO SAY AND SAVE- YOU
KNOW WHAT DO WE BELIEVE DO WE
BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD SAY. YEAH
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP PAYING THESE
POVERTY WAGES BECAUSE OF- THE
CHANCE THAT MIGHT THAT THAT. YOU
KNOW THAT COULD POSSIBLY HAPPEN
IT WAS A DISADVANTAGE IT'S NOT
LIKE YOU CAN'T SIGN THESE
PLAYERS FOR THREE MORE YEARS
RIGHT. OUR POINT IS YOU CAN SEND
ESPECIALLY MORE YEARS YOU YOU
MAY HAVE TO PAY THEM A HIGHER
SALARY. BUT YOU COULD IF YOU
WANT TO LOCK THEM UP FOR SEVEN
YEARS YOU CAN SELECT SOME OF FOR
SEVEN YEARS. YOU JUST HAVE TO
PAY A HIGHER SALARY- SO- THEN
WHY DO A CONTRACT FOR FOUR YEARS
IF YOU CAN STILL DO THAT.
BECAUSE THE POINT IS AFTER FOUR
YEARS BECAUSE WAY AND GET THE
WHOLE REASON FOR DOING THIS IS
YOU YOU HER FOR THE WITNESSES
THE WAGES THAT ARE BEING PAID
RIGHT NOW. AND AND SO- AFTER
FOUR YEARS AGAIN HE YOU KNOW THE
CAN YOU HEAR THE WITH US RIGHT
SO IN YOUR EIGHT YEARS DOING THE
EXACT SAME JOB MAKING TWELVE
TIMES AS MUCH. RIGHT TO OUR
POINT IS YES AFTER FIVE YEARS
YOU CAN BE DOING THE EXACT SAME
JOB MAKING TWELVE TIMES AS MUCH.
BUT THAT PRESUMES THAT THERE'S
ADVANTAGE TO THE PLAYER THAT THE
PLAYERS GOOD ENOUGH IN EVERY
INSTANCE FOR THAT TO HAPPEN AS
OPPOSED TO. VOTE MOVING IT UP
AND BEING MORE ARBITRARY MOVING
IT UP FORCES PEOPLE OUT OF THE
SYSTEM WHEN THEY WOULD NOT AVE
BEEN FORCED OUT OF THE SYSTEM
ANOTHERWAY AND IF IT IS IN FACT
FOREIGN BORN PLAYERS. THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IN THAT
CATEGORY THAT'S NOT A GOOD THING
YEAH I DO THINK IF YOU THINK
ABOUT IT THAT THIS NOTION THAT
SOMEHOW IT'S GONNA BE FORCED OUT
IT JUST DOESN'T. IT JUSTDOESN'T
MAKE SENSE SO JIM I'M NOT NO BUT
I MEAN I MEAN. IT TOOK TO JUST I
AM PLAYER. AFTER FOUR YEAR.
RIGHT SO RIGHT NOW. FOR MAKING
THOUSAND HOURS A WEEK I KEEP
MAKING THOUSAND DOLLARS A WEEK.
IN ORDER LEGISLATION YOU WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO NEGOTIATE. WITH
UP WITH A WHOLE BUNCH OF TEAMS.
IF NOBODY WANTS TO SIGN A AND MY
BEST OPTIONS STAY FOR THE
CURRENT TEAM MAKING A THOUSAND
DOLLARS A WEEK. I'M GONNA SAY
FOR THE CURRENT TEAM MAKING
THOUSAND HOURS A WEEK. SO NOBODY
IS BEING FORCED OUT JUST GIVE ME
THE OPTION NOW TO NEGOTIATE. A
HIGHER SALARY IF PEOPLE WANT ME.
MADHU KHANNA. BECAUSE AS AS NOT
TO READ THAT I GOT OF THE
SITUATION IF IT'S ENACTED. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE BILL
PROVIDES THAT THERE CAN'T BE A
CONTRACT MORE THAN FOUR YEARS.
SO THAT WE WOULD HAVE TO MAKE
THE DECISION OF WHETHER TO BRING
A PLAYER TO THE MAJOR LEAGUES
WITHIN FOUR YEARS. REGARDLESS OF
THEIR STATUS AND WHETHER THEY'RE
READY TO BE. A MATRICULATED TO
THE BIG LEAGUES- SO IT AFFECTS
HIGH SCHOOL PLAYERS IT AFFECTS.
FOREIGN BORN PLAYERS THAT ARE
SIGNED AT A YOUNGER AGE. COLLEGE
PLAYERS THAT ARE SIGNED. OLDER
THEY HAVE MORE BASEBALL
EXPERIENCE ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE
ABLE TO BE A VALUED WITHIN THAT
TIME FRAME. UNDER UNDER THIS
SCENARIO TWENTY FIVE MAJOR
LEAGUE CLUBS OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA WOULD SIGNED. SEVEN
YEARS. AND HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY
TO EVALUATE PLAYERS. AND TRADE
PLAYERS- AND BECOME MORE
COMPETITIVE THAN THE CALIFORNIA
BASED CLUBS THAT WOULD HAVE TO
MAKE A DECISION. ON PLAYERS. IN
MANY CASES WELL BEFORE THAT
DECISION IS RIGHT. SO I JUST
NEED TO CLARIFY THAT BECAUSE IF
THAT'S NOT CORRECT. THE BILL
RIGHT NOW THERE ARE MINOR LEAGUE
FREE AGENTS ARE PEOPLE WHO LAST
AND MY LEASE MORE THAN SEVEN
YEARS WE'RE NOT SAYING YOU HAVE
TO MAKE THE MAJORS. IN FOR YOUR
STARBUCKS. YOU CAN STILL BE A
MINOR LEAGUE FREE AGENT JUST AS
A MINOR LEAGUE FREE AGENT TODAY.
WHICH IS A I BELIEVE. THIS WOULD
BE AT. AFTER FOUR YEARS RATHER
MINOR LEAGUE FREE AGENCY AFTER
SEVEN YEARS. SO WE'RE NOT SAYING
YOU HAVE. CUT POP POP AND ROCK
WERE PROMOTED TO THE MAJORS.
WE'RE JUST SAYING HEY. IF YOU
KNOW THE MARINERS HAVE BEEN
WATCHING HIM FOR FOUR YEARS AND-
THEY WENT OFF A- FIRE DEAL. THEY
GOT FOR HER DEAL. THE GIANTS
COULD STILL MATCH THAT AT WORK
BEAT THAT DEAL- BUT NOT SAYING
YOU GOT FROM A SOMEBODY REMARKS.
STILL MORE. FOR THE REASON I
VALID FOR TRY TO THE ROUGH YOU
YES I WAS STILL GOING BACK THE
PREMISE AND I THINK YOU.
DRESSING SOMETHING ELSE. BECAUSE
THE PREMISES. THERE'S TWO HERE.
ONE IS WHETHER OR NOT THEY'D BE
SIGNED IN CALIFORNIA IN THE
FIRST PLACE. OUR CONVERSATION
HAS BEEN ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS AT
FOUR YEARS OR SEVEN YEARS. IF
THEY'RE NOT SIGNED IN CALIFORNIA
IN THE FIRST PLACE THERE IS NO
FOR YEARS OR THERE IS NO SEVEN
YEARS. BUT THE REAL THING. IS
THERE'S A PRESUMPTION. THAT
PABLO SANDOVAL. FOR THE WITNESS
THAT TESTIFIED. WOULD AT FOUR
YEARS BE ENTITLED TO THAT OR
RECOGNIZED AS A GOOD PLAYER AND
BE ENTITLED TO THAT. THAT BETTER
SALARY. A. N. AND THE THING I'M
TRYING TO GET AT. IS WHETHER
MOVING TO FREE AGENCY MOVES.
SYSTEM A BIT BECAUSE I DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH LEVERAGE ARE
PERCEIVED TO BE GOOD ENOUGH. A
CHECK. CHIU SOONER IN A WAY THAT
IS NOT TO THE ADVANTAGE OF THE
PLAYERS YEAH I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE
SAYING I'M TRYING TO ANSWER IT
WHICH IS STATE. THAT YOU WOULD
BE SAYING. LET'S LOCK EVERY
PLAYER INTO POVERTY WAGES FOR AN
EXTRA THREE YEARS. BECAUSE OF
THE POSSIBLE EDGE CASE OF
SOMEBODY IN THE BORDERLINE WHO'S
POSSIBLY DISADVANTAGE AND I'M
SAYING. THAT PERSON WOULD BE
DISADVANTAGED RIGHT BECAUSE
pFREE AGENT SO IF SOMEBODY WANTS
TO OFFER YOU MORE MONEY. THEN
YOU CAN DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT
YOU MIGHT SAY HEY ONE SERVICE
ORGANIZATION. I WANT TO STAY
WITH HER EXIST FOR THE SAME
AMOUNT. BUT IF NO ONE OFFERS YOU
MORE MONEY. THEN YOU'RE NO WORSE
OFF YOU CAN STILL STAY WITH THE
CURRENT ORGANIZATION- THAT YOU
EFFORTS TO ME THAT THEY WANT TO
PAY YOU. IF THEY'RE SIGNED IN
THE FIRST PLACE. IF THEY'RE
SIGNED A FIRST PLACE YEP. BUT
YET AGAIN THEN YOU'RE NOT
DISMISSING ANY PLAYERS THE
QUESTION IS ARE YOU JUST
VANISHING CALIFORNIA TEENS. NINE
ONE. WHAT MADE. IT IN CRAFTING
THE BILL WHAT MADE YOU CHOOSE
SEVEN YEARS AND FOR I MEAN FOR
YEARS AS OPPOSED TO SEVEN. WHAT
WHAT AND WHAT WAS THE BENCHMARK
FOR DOING WELL BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THAT FOR IT WE HAD TO
MAKE A CALL BUT WE LIVE FOUR
YEARS IS SUFFICIENT TO EVALUATE-
A PLAYER. AND SEVEN YEARS I WAS
IN THE CURRENT WEB RIGHT NOW.
BUT AGAIN JUST. PHYSICALLY SIGN
A PLAYER TO SEVEN YEARS YOU'RE
NOT OBLIGATED. TO KEEP THAT PLAY
FOR SEVEN YEARS PLAYERS GET CUT
ALL THE TIME. RIGHT SO THAT'S
WHY IT IS NOTION THAT. THEIR
SERVICE EDUCATE FOR SOME IS
DISADVANTAGED. I JUST DON'T
THINK THAT EDUCATE SUCCESS. UN
BUT THE- YEAH BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT COMMITTED TO KEEP SOMEONE
FOR SEVEN YEARS SO NOT. YOUR
IT'S NOT A GUARANTEED. YOU KNOW
SAY SEVEN YEAR- EMPLOYMENT- SO
AGAIN I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY.
IT WILL BE DISADVANTAGING PLAY.
THE QUESTION ARE YOU
DISADVANTAGING CALIFORNIA TEENS.
AND YOU KNOW A HERE IS LIKE I
THINK IT'S UPON US THE SURVEY
DECISION ARE WE GOING TO. STAND
UP FOR WORKERS AND- THE WAY. I
DID CALIFORNIA LEADS THE WAY I
THINK TO ME BASED GONNA HAVE TO
ADJUST. THIS IS IT LOOKS LIKE
THEY HAVE TO ADJUST IN IN OTHER
WAYS AROUND COMPENSATION OTHER
THINGS- JUST AS WE FOR SAID IN
MANY OTHER. YOU KNOW WITH MANY
OTHER PLACES WHERE CALIFORNIA'S
MOVE FIRST AND WE'VE MADE AND-
THE REST OF COUNTRIES CAUGHT UP
TO US AT YOU KNOW FUEL ECONOMY
WAIVERS OR OTHER THINGS. I THINK
THAT WERE BIG ENOUGH- THAT THE
SOLUTION WILL BE FOUND AND YOU
KNOW I DON'T KNOW NOT TO GO SHE
MAYBE SOME TEACHERS WOULD MAYBE-
YOU KNOW- MAYBE THEY WANT TO
COME UP WITH SOMETHING. ALONG
YOU KNOW FOR SURE. BUT FOR
PLAYERS COMING OUT OF COLLEGE
BUT- THE REALITIES RIGHT NOW YOU
CAN BE COMING OUT OF COLLEGE AT
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO YOU ARE
LOCKED UP FOR SEVEN YEARS. AT
THE WHICH IS- THAT THAT WE
IDENTIFIED IN ON JUST READ THOSE
TO YOU JUST TO BE YOU KNOW NOW
IT'S ON THE RECORD BUT LET ME IF
I CAN DO ONE FOLLOW UP ON THE
SUBJECT. HE I JUST GIVE YOU A
CHANCE TO COMMENT ON. WHAT WAS
JUST SAID. WELL THERE THERE IS
ANOTHER. HERE THERE'S A RULE
FIVE DRAFT FOR PLAYERS WITH FOUR
YEARS OF MINOR LEAGUE SERVICE
THAT ANOTHER TEAM CAN. SELECT
THEM- AND TAKE THEM ONTO THEIR
TEAM IF THEY ARE AT THE MAJOR
LEAGUE LEVEL S. IF A PLAYER IS-
AT THE OF THE- HAS THE ABILITY
TO JUMP TO THE MAJOR LEAGUES
THERE'S ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY FOR
THEM- IF THEIR CLUB IS. IS
HOLDING THEM BACK PEOPLE OF. AND
SO I THOUGHT IT WAS WORTH
MENTIONING THAT- SO AND THEN
JUST TO EMPHASIZE THE POINT THAT
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL AND
PLAYERS IN THE LITIGATION THAT'S
ONGOING OR DRESSING COMPENSATION
ISSUES AND BENEFIT ISSUES- AND
WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT THAT WILL BE
PRODUCTIVE I AND- THE MINOR
LEAGUE PLAYERS AND THE LEAKS
WILL HAVE- MODIFIED RUSHING. IN
IF THERE IS THE COMPENSATION
ISSUES AND BENEFITS ADDRESSED IN
THIS LITIGATION. IT WOULD AFFECT
WHAT THEY'RE PAID WHETHER IT'S
FOUR YEARS OR SEVEN YES OKAY SO
THAT WOULD ITS ONGOING
LITIGATION THERE ARE DISCUSSIONS
HAPPENING NOW I DON'T WANT TO
PRE JUDGE THEM- BUT WE BELIEVE
THAT THOSE SHOULD. BE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SUCCEED- AND SO I
AM THANKFUL THAT THE AUTHOR HAS.
NOT ADDED TO THAT WOMAN ONE
FOLLOW UP QUESTION BECAUSE IN
READING ANALYSIS AND TALKING TO
PEOPLE ON THE WAY HERE THE IT
SEEMS AND THE WITNESS EVEN- BOB
MENTIONED IT WHETHER IT'S
HOUSING OR TRANSPORTATION OR
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE PART OF
THE JOB. THAT ARE NOT DIRECTLY
INCLUDED IN COMPENSATION IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE IT STE
BY ORGANIZED BASEBALL DEAD THE
DEAD THAT THE COMPENSATION AND
BENEFITS SHOULD BE REALLY CLEAR
RATHER THAN IT BE OFF TO THE
SIDE IN SOME WAY. IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT'S IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE LAWSUIT- WILL MINOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL HAS- MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL'S ADDRESS THE
HOUSING ISSUE SO THERE'S NO
HOUSING SUBSIDIES FOR THE
PLAYERS- AND THERE'S FOOD-
TRANSPORTATION AND SO FORTH
THAT'S ALL PART. OF THE BENEFIT
PACKAGE THAT THE PLAYERS HAVE AS
WELL AS HEALTH INSURANCE ABOUT
ALL OF THESE ITEMS ARE PART OF
THE LITIGATION YES MA'AM. IN.
THE END WE- CLOSE OUR- OUR GONNA
CHIU THIS. THE AB RIGHT WHICH I
THINK GIVES OUR WITNESS WE HAVE
TREVOR SPEAK ON. ON A SOME OF
THESE QUESTIONS TO ABOUT FOUR
YEARS FOR SEVEN YEARS IF HE
THINKS HE WOULD HAVE BEEN
DISADVANTAGED. BY BY- I THINK HE
I'M NOT SURE THAT'S- THE YOU
KNOW WE COULD HAVE EVERY SINGLE
PLAYER. I TESTIFY I THINK IT'S A
MORE GENERIC QUESTION THAT THAN
THE INDIVIDUAL ONE I WANT TO
CHANGE THE SUBJECT. TWENTY NINE
NO I BEEN ASKING QUESTIONS
BECAUSE THE OTHER ONE IS THE
NAME IN IT IMAGE AND LIKENESS.
IN DIRT THE THING THAT WAS
RAISED IN DIFFERENT PLACES AND I
WANT YOU TO SPEAK TO IT. IT IS
THAT. A TEAM LOSES CONTROL OF-
THE WHAT A PLAYER MIGHT SAY
ABOUT THE CLUB OR THE GAME IF
IT'S INDEPENDENT HOW. WOULD THIS
BILL ADDRESS THAT ARE NOT
ADDRESS THAT. YES A- WE FEEL
THAT'S- PRETTY CLEAR THAT YOU
AGREEMENT CAN BE REACHED AT
PLAYERS AND OWNERS VIA THE UPC
IN TERMS OF WHAT TYPES OF
PRODUCTS THAT CAN CAN BE
ENDORSED I'M JUSTWITH THE NCAA
RIGHT D. THAT PLAYERS HAVE AN
IMAGE LIKENESS WE DON'T LET
PLAYERS- GO AND ENDORSE YOU KNOW
CIGARETTES OR OTHER THINGS RIGHT
SO- THE ADMISSION OF YOUR
QUESTIONS BUT WHAT WHAT WHAT
SORT OF LIKE I THINK WHAT I
HEARD. IS THAT THE TEAMS FEEL
LIKE THEY LOSE CONTROL OF THE
MESSAGE IS THERE A WAY WITHIN
YOUR BILL THAT THAT'S NOT TRUE
BUT THEY HAVE TO GET REWARDED
FOR NAME IMAGE AND LIKENESS YES
AGAIN WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
DOCUMENTED AND THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE NEGOTIATE JUST OTHER
PLACES RIGHT THEY CAN BE ABLE TO
NEGOTIATE THAT THERE'S NOTHING
THAT HARMS A MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL. I MEAN IT'S NOT
REQUIRED IT'S SOMETHING THAT
THEY WOULD NEGOTIATE ON EVERY
SITUATION YES AND I WOULD PREFER
TO- I'M JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S IN THE BILL
YES- IT ACCORDING TO. THE PEOPLE
THAT WE'VE TALKED TO- AROUND US
IT'S REALLY ABOUT MAKING CAN SO
WE TOOK A VIDEO GAME EXAMPLE
WHERE THEY CURRENTLY DO NOT GET
COMPENSATED FOR THAT- BUT THE
OTHER PIECE. EXACT MECHANICS
AKIN TO THE EXACT MECHANICS
HERE- FOR THIS PURPOSE OF THIS
DISCUSSION THERE ARE MECHANICS
TO MAKE SURE THAT- YOU CAN'T SAY
NEGOTIATE FOR CIGARETTES OR YOU
CAN'T DO SUPPORT FOR GAMBLING I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING. I JUST
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING ARE YOU SAYING THAT THAT
YOU HAVE IT NOW THIS IS
PROHIBITED NOW REGARDLESS OF
WHAT HAPPENS IN THIS ARTS
WITHOUT CHANGE THAT YEAH. WHAT
BUT IT. HE IT FOR HIM NOW AND
YOUR THAT THIS BILL NOT CHANGE.
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING BUT I
BELIEVE IT IS PROHIBITED NOW AND
I DON'T BELIEVE OUR BILL CHANGE
YES. ONE OFFICER TO WALKING TO
THE MICHAEL ASK YOU TO COMMENT
CENTER ARMS- SAN FERNANDO.
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR THE DODGERS. AND
THAT THE THING ABOUT THIS BILL
AND JUST WHO. I'M SORRY WHO THE
DODGERS I WAS ASKING ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR DRAWS. YEAH. THE
THING ABOUT THE BILL THAT'S
INTERESTING IS THAT IT HAS ONE
PROVISION THAT IS ALL
ENCOMPASSING AND USES THE WORD
INTERFERES. A CONTRACT CANNOT IT
THE BILL ACTUALLY SAYS A
CONTRACT CANNOT HAVE A PROVISION
THAT INTERFERES WITH THE
PLAYER'S. NAME IMAGE AND
LIKENESS RIGHT. THERE'S NO
DEFINITION OF WHAT INTERFERES
MEANS THE BILL THAT PURPORTS TO
GO ON TO GIVE THE CLUB SOME SORT
OF. RIGHT THAT IS A VERY
SPECIFIC ABOUT YOU KNOW
CONFLICTS BETWEEN WHAT THE
PLAYERS TRYING TO DEAL WITH THE
CLUBS TRYING TO DO. THAT IS BY
THE WAY BY A MUCH BROADER WAY
MUCH BROADER STANDARD THE
INTERFERES STANDARD. AN WHAT'S
IN THE MAJOR LEAGUE UNIFORM
PLAYER CONTRACT WHICH
SPECIFICALLY GIVES THE RIGHT.
THE CLUBS THE RIGHT TO REVIEW
AND APPROVE- THE USE OF NAME
IMAGE AND LIKENESS. UNDER
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES CHAU.
THAT'S WHY WE OPPOSE THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL AS IT IS
TODAY. AND I SHOULD POINT OUT AS
I DID EARLIER THE CURRENT MINOR
LEAGUE YOU UNIFORMED PLAYER
CONTRACT DOES NOT DEPRIVE A
PLAYER OF HIS AND I ALL RIGHTS
IT SIMPLY REQUIRES. THAT THE
CLUB REVIEW AND APPROVE THAT SO
THAT IT THEIR PROPERLY USED. IN
OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE PROPOSING
SOMETHING DO HELLO ONE LAST
QUESTION YOU'RE PROPOSING
SOMETHING DIFFERENT SO YOU DON'T
THINK THAT WORKS- THIS IS
EXACTLY THE NCA SITUATION THIS
IS REALLY WELL DOCUMENTED VERY
EASY TO FIGURE OUT IF THERE'S
ANY- CERTAINLY- WE'RE NOT GONNA
DO ANYTHING WE MADE IT VERY
CLEAR. THAT WOULD GIVE THE BY
BUT I'VE READ I ASKED A
DIFFERENT QUESTION BIG BIG
BECAUSE THEY STATED THE WHITE
ITS OPERATING AND YOUR BILL
CHANGES THE WAY IT'S OPERATING
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT THE WAY
IT'S OPERATING NOW NEEDS TO BE
CHECKED. WHAT WE THINK IT'S NEED
TO CHECK. THE BILL CHANGES FROM
WHAT HE SAID. THE COST REGARDING
AND IT. DOESN'T IT STATE'S
PLAYERS WILL NOT MAKE PUBLIC
APPEARANCES PARTICIPANT RATER
TELEVISION OR ONLINE COMPUTER
FORMS OR ANY OTHER PUBLIC
CONFERENCES OR ANY SUPPORT. SO
WE BELIEVE THAT A PERSON FROM
PROFITING FROM VIDEO GAMES. AND
OTHER ITEMS OUTSIDE THEIR JOB
RESPONSIBILITIES. AND YEAH
THAT'S WHICH I CHANGE THAT
SMELLS ABOUT. SENATOR I WOULD
ASK SENATOR BACKER TO FINISH
READING THE PARAGRAPH FROM THE
UNIFORMED PLAYER CONTRACT. YOU
ARE I DON'T HAVE THAT PIECE HERE
BUT- ONE IS THIS THE RIGHT AFTER
THE NCAA SITUATION. WE'RE NOT
GONNA DO ANYTHING- THAT- YOU
KNOW THAT THIS IS THE SORT OF
WELL DOCUMENTED PIECE. AND WE
CAN IF THERE'S ANY CLEAR PRIMACY
BE TAKEN WE CAN TAKE UP. BUT THE
REALITY IS WE HAVE PLAYERS I'M
STILL TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHY
THAT DOESN'T WORK AND WHY YOU
FEEL LIKE IT HAS TO CHANGE IT
WAS A VIDEO GAME YOU JUST READ
WHAT'S IN THERE BUT I WAS TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND WHY. YOU THINK IT
NEEDS TO. GAME OUT SEVEN DOLLAR
VIDEO GAME MIGHT PLAYERS ARE
THEIR THEY'RE NOT BENEFIT A
PENNY. THAT'S WHAT NEEDS TO
CHANGE. AND TO COULD
CLARIFY TO MEMBERS GOING
FORWARD. IN JUDICIARY IF WE NEED
TO CLARIFY- THIS OTHER PIECE WE
BELIEVE. THAT THAT THAT PART IS
VERY CLEAR- AND THAT TO ANY
OTHER CONCERNS. ARE UNWARRANTED
THE PLAYERS JUST WANT A PIECE OF
THAT RECORD. THANK YOU I'M SORRY
ONE LONGER THAN NINE INTENDED
BUT THIS. I JUST HAVE TO TELL
YOU I'M NOT SURE THIS IS.
TOTALLY CLEAR- TOTALLY TOGETHER
I'M TOTALLY UNDERSTANDABLE THE
REASON FOR TEN I AM REALLY
STRUGGLING WITH THAT BECAUSE
NORMALLY I GIVE ME FINISH
NORMALLY I GIVE THE AUTHOR A
CHANCE TO WORK IT OUT AND I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHETHER
THERE'S- SOMETHING HERE THAT CAN
BE WORKED OUT. AND THAT'S WHAT
SORT OF UNCLEAR YEAH JUST ANSWER
WE WOULD BE DOING THE BILL IF
EVERYTHING'S CO PATHETIC THE
REALITY IS. THEY ARE UNDERSTAND
THE POINT I'M TRYING TO MAKE IS
THAT WE DO BILLS ALL THE TIME
JUST LOOK AT THE ENERGY
DEREGULATION IT WAS SORT OF
CLEAR HERE'S OUR VALUES HERE SO
WE HAVE TO DO. THE CONSEQUENCES
WERE SO ON INTENDED THAT WE
DON'T WITH THEM FOR YEARS AND SO
I GET WHAT OUR VALUES ARE OUR
VALUES ARE REALLY CLEAR YOU'RE
ACTING OUT OF THE VALUES BUT I
CAN'T TELL IF WHAT THE BILL
DOES. MATCHES THAT AND DOESN'T
HAVE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AND
ISN'T MUCH BROADER THAN IT
SHOULD BE SO THAT'S WHAT I'M
STRUGGLING WITH IN THE EARLY YOU
CAN DEAL WITH IT IN THE CLUB.
YEAH THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
MUCH TO BOTH OF YOU WHAT ARE.
CONVERSE CENTER NEWMAN DO YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
I DO AND I APOLOGIZE FOR BEING
LATE INTO FIND. IF ANY THIS IS
DUPLICATIVE I APOLOGIZE IN
ADVANCE. I WANT TO COME BACK TO
THIS DISCUSSION OF- SEVEN USERS
FOR YEARS TO PLAY CONTROL AT THE
FOR MR BERGAN SEEMS VERY. AND I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU MENTIONED OR
TALKED ABOUT SIGNING BONUSES THE
AND THEIR IMPACT. ON NOT OLY
THE BUSINESS MODEL GENERALLY BUT
ON HOW YOU THINK ABOUT THOSE.
YOU KNOW THE DIFFERENCE IN THOSE
FOREIGN SEVEN AND HOW IT MIGHT
INFLUENCE YOUR- TREATMENT OF
TALENT- IF THAT WOULD CHANGE.
THE LOOK OF A WITNESS ADDRESS IT
AFTERWARDS OKAY BECAUSE HE WAS
NOT HERE FOR THAT. YEAH I CAN I
CAN TELL YOU IN TWO THOUSAND ONE
THE AVERAGE SIGNING BONUS WAS
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS. PER PLAYER BUT
THAT DOESN'T APPLY TO ALL
PLAYERS IT'S A RANGE- FROM
FAIRLY LOW. VERY VERY HIGH
FIGURE. SO THAT'S THE ARAB.
SIGNING BONUS FOR A PLAYER SO
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY PART OF THE
CONSIDERATION THE PLAYERS ARE.
LEARNING JOURNEY TO BE CLEAR I
MEAN YOU KNOW ON AVERAGE. A
PLAYER INJURED PLAYERS GETTING
SOME OUTSIDE OF US. AND THAT'S
BEING ADVERTISED ACROSS THE
LENGTH OF TEAM CONTROL. RIGHT SO
YOU KOW TO SOME EXTENT THEY MAY
BE- YOU TAKE A CHANCE ON THEIR
JOB THEY HAVE RECEIVED SOME
COMPENSATION IN ADVANCE- AND
THAT IS THE BASIS FOR SOME OF
THE TOWN THAT YOU WISH YOU
SEARCHES YOU MAKE CORRECT. YES
OBVIOUSLY THE PLAYERS THAT ARE
PERCEIVED AS- MORE TALENTED A
RECEIVE. HIGHER SIGNING BONUSES
THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY ALWAYS.
ACROSS THE BOARD IT DEPENDS ON-
YOU KNOW ARE THEY COLLEGE PLAYER
OR THEY HIGH SCHOOL PLAYER AND
THERE'S A LOT OF VARIABLES AT
PLAY. SURE IF YOU'RE DURATION
YOUR CONTROLS LIMIT OF FOUR
YEARS WITH THAT CHANGE. HOW YOU
WOULD APPROACH THE BONUSES IF
YOU HAD. LESS LESS TIME TO
EVALUATE TALENTLESS TIME TO THE
REAL ESTATE INVESTMENT. I THINK
CLUBS WOULD BE LOW TO SIGN
PLAYERS FOR HIGH SIGNING BONUSES
THAT THEY DIDN'T BELIEVE THAT
PLAYER WOULD BE READY TO PLAY IN
THE MAJORS WITHIN THE FOUR YEAR
TIME FRAME. WHICH WOULD MEAN
THAT INTERNATIONAL LEE- FOREIGN
BORN PLAYERS FOR HIGH SCHOOL
PLAYERS WOULD BE LESS LIKELY TO
BE SIGNED. AND LESS LIKELY TO BE
SIGNED FOR. HIGHER SIGNING
BONUSES. PRECIADO TO SERVE THANK
YOU OR CLARIFYING SO COMING
BACK TO THE AND I'LL DISCUSSION
OF WITH THE FLEET OKAY. CAN I
DON'T KNOW GOOD SIR. NOPE BUT
SENATE RECORD BUDGET DID HER
WITNESS OF THE BECAUSE THERE
WITNESS FOR NOT INVESTMENT JUST
SO YOU KNOW. SO THE FULL LENGTH
OFTHE PC PLAYERS TO PAY FOR PER
WEEK AT THE COMPLEX WE LEVEL.
FIVE HUNDRED PER WEEK A SINGLE A
LEVEL SIX HUNDRED PER WEEK IT'S
AVAILABLE. WE AT DOUBLE A. OF
THESE ARE NOT WHO ARE GET. BIG
SIGNING BONUSES SO I WOULDN'T
EXPECT- THAT THAT THREE THREE OF
THE AVERAGE CAN BE MISSED. SO IT
TWENTY FIVE POINT IT WOULD BE
GOOD TO HEAR FROM OUR WITNESS-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES AT THE CLOSING. STRETCH
THAT SINCE THEN IMAGES GOD BUT I
THINK YOU MADE IT CLEAR I DON'T
KNOW THAT YOUR WITNESS BUT IT
TOO MUCH WHAT. I DID MY IT DOES
IT'S GOING TO BE THE THINKCENTRE
LATER COVERED A LOT OF THIS- THE
QUESTION AROUND AND- I. L.
ISSUES. YOU KNOW. IS THIS TRULY
LIKE THE INCIDENT LET FOR MR
FERNANDES AND SOAK IT MAY AS I
UNDERSTAND IT MAY BE TRUE FOR
VIDEO GAMES BUT IT'S REALLY NOT
TRUE FOR OTHER. APPLICATIONS ARE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THAT MIGHT
PRESENT THEMSELVES THE PLAYERS
FOR NAME IMAGE LIKENESS DEALS.
WELL THE ISSUE WHEN AND I'LL THE
NC DOUBLE A ISSUE WAS THAT THE
PLAYERS HAVE NO RIGHTS. I AS I
pPLAYER CONTRA. POLITICAL PLAYER
DOES THEIR- PARTS TO THAT PROVE.
THE FIRST PART GRANT THE CLUB.
THE RIGHT TO. YOU GOING NEED IN
ORDER TO DO EVERYTHING FROM
PROMOTED TEAM YOU KNOW. MAKE
BOBBLE HEADS- DO BROADCAST
EXETER EXETER THAT'S THERE'S A
GRANT OF. THERE THERE'S THE
SECOND PART. IS THE PART THAT
EXPLAINS YOU KNOW THAT
BASICALLY- GIVES THE CLUB THE
RIGHT TO REVIEW AND APPROVE THE
USE. OF THE PLAYERS- AND I ALL
RIGHT. BUT THE PROVISION ITSELF
PRESERVES THE PLAYERS AND I ALL
RIGHTS BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
PREVENT THE PLAYER FROM
EXERCISING INDEPENDENT AND I OWE
YOU KNOW INDEPENDENTLY
EXERCISING. THE AND I ALLRIGHT
AND DOING THE DEAL PROVIDED IT'S
APPROVED BY THE COURT. AND
SERVICE TO REQUIRE THE NC DOUBLE
A DID IN FACT PROHIBIT. THAT
ENHANCE MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THE NC DOUBLE A PROHIBITED
PLAYERS FROM DOING THAT AND- IT
WAS REQUIRED THAT THEY BE. THAT
THAT PROHIBITION BE LIFTED IN
ESSENCE. AND BY THE WAY THE- THE
USE OF AN AYE ALL RIGHTS IT IS
ALSO AS I INDICATED. SUBJECT TO
REVIEW AND APPROVAL. I ON THE
SPECIFIC. MAJORLY UNIFORMS
CONTRACT. THE BILL- THAT'S ALL I
HAVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND
JUST TO BE FAIR I KNOW THERE'S A
LOT OF BACK AND FORTH IN
NORMALLY WE THERE'S A THERE'S A
LITTLE MORE CAUTION ABOUT WHO
SPEAKS AT WHAT TIME- AND I WANT
TO BE FAIR SENATOR BAKER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO IN YOUR WITNESS TO
ADDRESS ONE LAST QUESTION I'LL
GIVE THEM. ONE MINUTE TO ADDRESS
AND THEY WILL HAVE YOU DO YOUR
CLOSING STATEMENT YEAH LIKE TO
WITNESS TO- I TREVOR JUST
ADDRESS IF YOU THOUGHT HE BE
pFREE AGENT AFTER FOUR YEARS- AND
IF HE HAS ANY OTHER COMMENT
ABOUT- THIS BUT ANY OF THE OTHER
DISCUSSION FUTURE. OKAY JERRY
HAVE ONE MINUTE HI. HI YES- NO I
DON'T THINK I'D BE DISADVANTAGED
HI MY CONTRACT MY INITIAL
CONTACT WITH ONLY FOUR YEARS-
EVEN IF YOUR INITIAL CONTACT IS
SEVEN YEARS LIKE MONOLITH THAT
DOESN'T GUARANTEE YOU SEVEN
YEARS PLAYING MINOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL THEY CAN CATCH YOU YOUR
FIRST SPRING TRAINING WHICH I'VE
SEEN. AND THEY CAN KEEP YOU IN
THE MINOR LEAGUES ALL OF TO PULL
YOU UP BEFORE CONTRACTORS EITHER
SO YOU KNOW I THINK THAT IS RE
SIGNING THE CONTRACTS THE BATES. NINTH AND TENTH YEARS. THE
SECOND ONE IS UNDERDOG BECAUSE-
THEY K. BEACON. AREA PAY THEM A
- WAY ACTUALLY YEAR OF FINALLY
NO I DON'T THINK IT I THINK IT
HELP PLAYERS FASHION GET HIRED
STARTING A SHIFT USER ORALLY
ENCOURAGED TO BE IN A NATION
THAN THAT'S IT. AND MAYBE GIVE
JUST A SIGNING BONUS. WHAT WAS
YOUR SIGN BONUS. AT CAL BERKELEY
. THOUSAND BUCKS THOSE THOUSAND
BUCKS A TWENTY THREE AND THEN
FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE
DOLLARS AFTER TAX. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TREVOR SENATOR RECORD
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SURE
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THE- ROBUST
DISCUSSION AND- ENGAGEMENT AND
THAT WAS FOR THAT CENTER ARCHER
HERE- BECAUSE HE'S APPRECIATE
HIS ENGAGEMENT WITH OUR- TEAM I
THINK THAT THE QUESTION IS- IF
WE BELIEVE IN ANY WAY THAT. THAT
FORCED TO CONTROL. THE PLAYERS
TO BE CONTROLLED FOR SEVEN YEARS
IS SOMEHOW IN THEIR BEST
INTEREST. I THINK THAT IS A- IS-
KIND OF CLEARLY A LAUGHABLE-
PROPOSITION- SO I THINK THAT THE
QUESTION HERE IS YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW THE TEAMS ARE
CONCERNED FOR THEIR-
COMPETITIVENESS. I THINK THAT.
YOU KNOW AGAIN IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA LEAD
AND I THINK THE RIGHT THING WILL
FOLLOW. UN IF THAT WERE TO
SOMEHOW- NOT HAPPENED THIS PAST
AND WE FOUR YEAR CONTRACTS IN
THAT AND SUCH. AGAIN PLAYER YOU
KNOW TEAMS HERE CAN STILL SIGN
SOMEONE FOR AN ADDITIONAL THREE
YEARS OF HER LIFE SO I JUST
THINK IT ANY ANY PROPOSITION
THAT SOMEHOW. CHANGING THIS I
MEAN AGAIN I'M SURE I WAS NOT
AROUND FREE AGENCY BUT I'M SURE
THE EXACT SAME ARGUMENTS WERE
MADE HOW THIS THE FRIDGE SHE WAS
GETTING ATTACHMENT- SOMEHOW- TO
THE PLAYERS- AND- YOU KNOW AND-
LUCKILY YOU KNOW I THINK
PREVAILED AND- I'LL GET THE KERR
FLIGHT CASE AND WE HAVE. A FREE
AGENCY UN SO I THINK THAT'S
REALLY THAT THE KEY POINT HERE
IS WE BELIEVE THAT ALLOWING
PLAYERS TO CONTROL IN SEVEN
YEARS. AT THE SALARIES THAT WE
ARE NOW WITH THE SIGNING BONUS
THAT WE HEARD IT'S PROBABLY ON
AVERAGE- IS IN THE PLAYER'S BEST
INTEREST NO. CLEARLY IT'S NOT.
QUESTION ARE WE WILLING TO. A
STEP FOR. IF THERE'S ISSUES AND
I OUT WERE HAPPY TO LOOK AT
THEM. THAT WE KNOW THERE'S THIS
GAME FOR EXAMPLE THEY DON'T GET
PAID FOR- BUT WE'RE NOT GONNA
ALLOW THEM TO GO OUTSIDE YOU
KNOW THERE WILL STILL BE. I'M
SURE I JUST KNOW THAT THERE ARE
WAYS TO. MAKE SURE AND I THINK
THAT I DON'T THINK A BILL
CHANGES THAT- WHERE TEAMS CAN
CONSENT- TO. TO YOU KNOW IT CAN
TO MAKE SURE IS NO DAMAGE TO THE
BRAND TEAM. SO I THINK THAT'S
NOT AN ISSUE. AND AGAIN I
APPRECIATE THE WITNESS
APPRECIATE THE- DISCUSSION AND-
I TO PUT- ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE SO
THAT WE CAN- MOVE FORWARD. AND-
CONTINUE THESE DISCUSSIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
RECORD DO YOU MOTION SB TWELVE
FORTY EIGHT. SO WHO COULD NOT
MAKE ANOTHER COMMENTERS THAT-
FOR THE- ON THE. CERTAINLY OKAY
I JUST WANNA I THANK THE AUTHOR-
I KNOW WHERE HIS HEART IS IT'S
WHERE MY HEART IS AS FAR AS
MAKING SURE THAT WORKING PEOPLE
REGARDLESS OF THEIR OF THEIR
CAREER OF YOU KNOW GET A FAIR
SHAKE AND SOMETIMES IT TAKES
LEGISLATION SOMETIMES IT TAKES
LITIGATION SOMETIMES IT HAPPENS
FOR ALL THE RIGHT REASONS- I- I
AM CONCERNED ABOUT A NUMBER OF
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN. BROUGHT
UP AND DUMP I'M HOPING THAT
SOMEHOW THE COMBINATION OF.
DIFFERENT LANGUAGE AMENDMENTS
MAYBE IT'S A LITIGATION I'M NOT
EXACTLY SURE THE COMBINATION OF
ALL THOSE. BOTH ADDRESS. EIGHT
CHANGE IN- FOR THE PLAYERS THAT
FOR THE GOOD OF THE PLAYERS- BUT
THERE'S STILL A LOT MORE TO BE
WORKED OUT SO- I'M SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL BUT- NOT A LOT MORE
WORK NEEDS TO BE DONE I THINK IN
ORDER FOR THIS TO GET ANYWHERE.
IF THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO. AND I REALLY APPRECIATE OF
THE MANAGEMENT COMING IN AND
ADDRESSING THESE THESE QUESTIONS
THIS IS. NOT AN EASY THING TO DO
WITH. THANK YOU I'M GONNA THINK
TWICE HERE FOR- FOR PRESIDING
AND SHE JUST HANDED THE GAVEL
BACK TO ME- AS A RETURN FROM.
ANOTHER COMMITTEE- AND I KNOW ON
THE AUTHOR'S CLOSED IN- IN I
DIDN'T HAVE A CHANCE TO MAKE
COMMENTS I'M NOT GONNA MAKE
EXTENSIVE COMMENTS BECAUSE OF
THE- THE CENTURY BECAUSE OF THE-
MEDICAID OF THE OF THE COMMITTEE
PROCEED. IF YOU WILL I DO WANT
TO ASSOCIATE- WHAT COMMENTS I
WOULD HAVE MADE WITH WITH
SENATOR CROSS WHO JUST SAID IN.
A DEPRECIATE THOUGH THE AUTHOR
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE-
WORKING WITH ME- BUT I DO AGREE
WITH SENATOR ACROSS SO THAT-
THERE'S- I DIDN'T HEAR THE REST
OF THE COMMENTARY BY THE
COMMITTEE BUT THERE'S- IN AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF- TRIPWIRES
HERE GOING FORWARD THAT. NEED TO
BE RESOLVED SO I'M GONNA STOP
THERE AND I'M ASKED THE
CONSULTANT TO- TO CALL ROLL CALL
PLEASE THANK YOU. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
COURTESY HI COURTESY I OR CHOI
BOGUE. A TROUBLED NOW THE
RUSSELL. THE RUSSELL I LAYERED.
NEWMAN. TWO FOUR- THE BILL FILLS
WITH TO AYE VOTES. TO CORRECT
THIS ONE RIGHT FIGURE ONE TWO TO
ONE- WITH REST THE COMMITTEE LÀ
Mí
WE WILL MOVE TO OUR NEXT. THE
NEXT BILL IN THIS HEARING WOULD
BE SENATOR UMBERG CENTER OF
BURKE HERE. IT WAS A CONSENT MY
APOLOGIES. YOU KNOW SAID SO FAR
THE VISSER HERE ON BOTH THE
CONSENT AGENDA THAT WOULD BE
GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
THAT OF THE CONSENT- I READ I
READ THE CONSENT BILLS EARLIER I
DON'T THINK I NEED TO DO THAT
AGAIN BUT JUST IN CASE IT'S SB
THIRTY FIVE S. B. TEN SIXTY FOUR
SB ELEVEN SIXTY EIGHT. IN SB
FOURTEEN OH TWO SO NOW EVERYONE
KNOWS INCLUDING HE WAS ON
CONSENT- SO WE HAVE THAT MOTION
SO IF YOU CALL THE ROLL PUT THE
MOTION IS CONSENT FOR SB FORTINO
TOO SB EIGHT THIRTY FIVE SB TEN
SIXTY FOUR AND SB ELEVEN SIXTY
EIGHT COURTESY. HI COURTESY I OR
TROUBLED. A TROUBLED BY THE
RUSSELL THE RUSSELL I LAYERED ON
. THERE I KNEW. NEWMAN AYE FIVE
SIR OKAY SO THE CONSENT- THE
CONSPICUOUS OUT ITS APPROVED-
FIVE FIVE TWO ZERO VOTE- SO NOW
WE WILL MOVE TO THE NEXT NON
CONSENT ITEM IN ORDER WE HEARD
CENTER RIGHT- IT'S BUILT EARLIER
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE BE NEXT SO
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO SENATOR
ROSES BILL. SB. THIRTEEN FIFTY
ONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YES YOU
MAY PROCEED IF READY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THIS IS ON-
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE
OF. ABOUT USE UP PRESSURE
PROGRAMS THE PANDEMIC HAS REALLY
CHANGED OUR WAY OF LIFE WHICH I
KNOW WE HEAR OVER AND OVER
AGAIN. BUT NOW WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REBUILD- THROUGH
A WORKER CENTERED FUTURE AND
CREATE LITERALLY MILLIONS OF
GOOD PAYING JOBS AND MEET OUR
CLIMATE GOALS IN IN ORDER TO
BUILD AN INCLUSIVE EQUITABLE
GREEN ECONOMY WE NEED TO GROW
AND SUPPORT THE NEXT GENERATION
THE NEXT GENERATION OF WORKING
PEOPLE WE CANNOT ALLOW
GENERATIONS OF YOUTH. TO BE
DISCONNECTED AND LEFT BEHIND WE
NEED THAT TO MEET OUR GOALS WE
NEED ENGINEERS AND NURSES LIKE
TRADITIONS LABOR'S PARK RANGERS
PIPE TRADES JOURNEY LEVELS
SOCIAL WORKERS AND EDUCATORS SO
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM AND CREATES THE OFFICE
OF THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM WITHIN
THE DIVISION OF APPRENTICESHIP
STANDARDS AT THE LABOR AGENCY.
GRANT FUNDS WILL BE AWARDED TO
ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS TO DEVELOP
NEW APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS OR
EXPAND EXISTING APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS. THIS OF YOUTH
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM WILL
COMPLEMENT AND IT WILL EXPAND
PRE APPRENTICESHIP AND
APPRENTICESHIP IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE THE AVERAGE AGE OF
APPRENTICES AND PRE APPRENTICES
CONTINUES TO CLIMB WHILE THE
YOUTH UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IS MUCH
HIGHER THAN FOR OLDER WORKERS.
OF THE EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND A
PLUS APPRENTICES IN CALIFORNIA
ONLY POINT 2% OUR YOUTH WE
LACKED THE PROGRAMS AND THE
FLEXIBILITY FOR YOU TO ENTER
INTO EMERGING AND GROWTH
INDUSTRIES EVEN IN A THRIVING
ECONOMY. CALIFORNIA'S MAKING
HISTORIC INVESTMENTS IN OUR WORK
FORCE WITH A FOCUS ON HIGH ROAD
JOBS AND TRAINING WE MUST INVEST
IN OUR YOUTH WE MUST ROVIDE
CONNECTIONS TO QUALITY JOBS AND
TRAINING. LOSE JOBS RIGHT NOW WE
ARE AT THE RISK OF LOSING
DECADES OF EXPERIENCE IN
IMPORTANT SECTORS IS OUR WORK
FORCE RIGHT RETIREES UP RETIRES
IN HIGH NUMBERS GOVERNOR NEWSOM
ESTABLISHED A GOAL FOR
CALIFORNIA TO DEVELOP FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND NEW APPRENTICES
OVER THE NEXT DECADE. IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET WE'RE LOOKING AT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS TO INVEST IN
WORKFORCE TRAINING. FOCUSED ON
CLIMATE THE CARE ECONOMY AND-
ESTABLISHING PIPELINES FOR YOUTH
TO ENTER THE GROWTH INDUSTRIES
THROUGH ON THE JOB TRAINING THAT
ALLOWS THEM TO EARN AND LEARN IS
A PROVEN PRACTICE. OF. IS A
PROVEN TO JOB AT LEAST GOOD JOB
AND CAREERS. AND PROVIDES K.
WITH THE AND SKILLS WE NEED-
SUCH DATE WE HAVE TO WITH TO. IS
THE- FROM THE SIDE. AND ERIC
MORRISON SMITH FROM THE ALLIANCE
FOR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR. THANK
YOU SENATOR ALSO WILL CALL ON
ERIC MORRISON SMITH FIRST. YOU
ARE AVAILABLE YOU MAY PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON AUDIBLE SHERRIN
AND- MY NAME IS ERIC MORE WITH
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
ALLIANCE OF BOYS METABOLIC- WITH
THE NETWORK OF TWENTY
ORGANIZATIONS WORKING TO
TRANSFORM THAT THEM THAT ARE
COMING BOYS MEN OF COLOR THE
FAMILY THE COMMUNITY. AND WE ARE
PROUD CO SPONSOR SB THIRTY
THIRTY ONE- YOU KNOW IF THE
MOMENT YOU'LL HEAR FROM IS THE-
BUT WE KNOW THAT YOUNG PEOPLE
ACROSS CALIFORNIA NEED ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES AND CAREERS THAT
LEAD TOSELF SUFFICIENCY. AT THE
SAME TIME CALIFORNIA'S ALSO
DEALING WITH AN AGING WORKFORCE
WHICH MEANS WE'RE AT RISK OF
LOSING DECADES. OF EXPERIENCE IN
A FOR INSPECTORS. WE LOOK AT PRE
APPRENTICESHIP AND UP. OUR
APPROACH TO BOTH. KNOWLEDGE IN
SKILLS AND- WORKERS. BUT YOU
WILL WORK. WELCOME WITH YOUR
INDUSTRY. PACE LEARN THE HIGH
DOLLAR. HI THIS. ARE CRITICAL
FARRAKHAN. GIVEN THAT AVERAGE
AGE OF A- THIRTY THREE FIBA. THE
CALIFORNIA YOU COULD BE TO-
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM WILL HELP
BUILD. A STRONG TO THE PUBLIC
EFFORT STRUCTURE AND IT PASSED
WITH THE HELP MORE YOUNG PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
DISCONNECTED MONFORT COMMITTEE
GO FROM YOUTH APPRENTICE THE PRE
APPRENTICE AND APPRENTICESHIP.
PROGRAMS- GOOD CAREER. AND IF
THE HIGH A COUPLE THINGS THAT
THE BILL DOES- THE FIRST THING
IS THAT THE FINE IN STATURE BUT
PREPARED TO SHIP IS. EIGHT YOUTH
APPRENTICESHIP OFFICE WHICH WILL
PROVIDE GRANTS TO COMPLEMENT AND
EXPAND PRE OF EXISTING.
EXPANDING YOUR PRACTICE IT IT
PROVIDE A FULL HEATPROOF
FLEXIBLE ACCORDING TO STATEWIDE
FRAMEWORK AND STRATEGY TO HELP
YOU SURE THAT YOU THE FRIENDSHIP
AREN'T ALIGNED IT WITH THE
FRESHEST. IN INDUSTRY NEEDS AND
LASTLY THE PROGRAMMER CRAIG
ONRAMP OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL YOU
BUT ESPECIALLY THOSE YOUNG
ADULTS WHO ARE BETWEEN THE AGES
OF FIFTEEN AND TWENTY FOUR BABY
ON HOW. LIVING IN CONCENTRATED
POVERTY AND I'VE BEEN TO THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM OR
PICKING BERRIES LABOR MARKET
PARTICIPATION AND ENSURE THAT
THEY GET THE WRAPAROUND. SERVICE
THEY NEED TO PARTICIPATE.
OFFICEDEPOT WOULD WANT TO THIS
RIGHT. IN THE BILL INCLUDING
YEAR WITH ALL THE- WILL BE. WE
GET INTO THE DETAILS AND ENSURE
WE BOTH THE TOPICAL THAT. VERY
IMPROPER THIS TYPE OF PROGRAM
ANOTHER STATE. AND ALIGNED WITH
THE GOVERNOR TOLD THE FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND OFFENSIVE BY
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY NINE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. ALL RIGHT
THANKS FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND
LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS NUMBER TWO
WOULD BE IZZY. IZZY IF YOU'RE
THERE YOU MAY PROCEED. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES. OKAY HI MY NAME
IS IZZY I AM A ONE O'CLOCK YOU
AND I WAS INVOLVED IN THE TWENTY
ONE YEAR- I. ONE SUPPORT THIS
BILL BECAUSE AFTER BEING
INVOLVED THE GRAPHICAL MANY
YEARS I TRIED GET INTERNSHIPS I
GOT AN INTERNSHIP FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF THE
STATE OF THE PAPERWORK TAKE
EIGHT MONTHS TO WHERE IT'S-
GONNA BE HONEST A THREE YEAR. AT
THE LIVING UP WITH THAT TIME-
AND THEN DOING INTERNSHIP HAS
ALLOWED ME TO BUILD MY CAREER
AND MAYBE DO BETTER THE PAVEMENT
ON THE U. I'VE BEEN ABLE TO HAVE
EXPANDED THE LEARNING GARDEN
INDIVIDUAL AND PROFESSIONAL. AND
GETTING PAID OFF OF THE HOUSE
BECAUSE THEY ONLY HAVE THE
ABILITY AND BUILT. THE BILLION
MY LIFE. FEB I BELIEVE THAT
HAVING THE BILL IT IS THE OF THE
- THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME OR
ANYTHING TO SOME USER ANYONE
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHICH
IS SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF US
THIRTEEN ONE SO COMPORT. WE'LL
SEE NONE OF THEM WILL GO TO
MODERATOR. MODERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY SUPPORT TESTIMONY
ON THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE- YEAH LET
US KNOW THE NUMBER IF ANY. AND
THOSE THAT ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
FOUR ZERO AT THIS TIME. YEAH ONE
ZERO FOUR SUPPORT. MR THIS TIME
WE DO ABOUT FIVE IN OUR QUEUE
WILL BE JUST A MOMENT. THANK YOU.
THEY WILL FIRST GO TO LINE FORTY
THESE YOU HAVE. HI THIS IS JON
HERE TO THE CALIFORNIA
OPPORTUNITY YOUTH NETWORK FORD
F. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE THANK
YOU. NEXT WILL BE NUMBER FORTY
FIVE. FIVE YEAH HI. YOU'VE WELL
AND A GIRL WE WERE AT THIRTEEN
FIFTY ONE ALONG WITH THE
ORGANIZATION ENTRANCE NEAR YOU
COMPOUND SERVICES THAN YOU
THOUGHT COOPERATIVE OF IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. WELL NOW
GO TO NUMBER TWENTY FIVE. GOOD
ARMONK HAVE SORRY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RECALL CONSTRUCTIVE
OFFICE WILL HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION ON THE BILL VERY LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
OFFICE OFFICE ON THE ELEVENTH
REQUIRED FOR NATION THAT'S ALL
YOU THAT'S YOU'RE ALLOWED SAY ON
THIS- MODERATOR IF YOU MOVE ON
PLEASE THE SYSTEM THOSE THESE
LINES OR SUPPORT. OR OPPOSITION
THE NAME AFFILIATION. IMPOSITION
THANK YOU. NEXT TO THE NUMBER.
FORTY FOUR. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS SERRA SODA AND THEN THE
CHAIR OF THE YOUTH OF
COLLABORATIVE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT A YES
VOTE ON SB. THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE.
THANKS IS NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN.
HELLO MY NAME OF MY ADULT FOR A
AND I WORK FOR YOU WELL I'M ALSO
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN
OUR COMMUNITY HEALERS I SUPPORT
SB THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE. YOUR
CHAIR AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE. OKAY THANK
YOU MODERATOR- WE HAVE NO LEAD
OPPOSITION ON SB THIRTEEN FIFTY
ONE- SO ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO TAKE IN OPPOSE
POSITION HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM- IF SO PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
ASSENAGON A MODERATOR IF YOU CAN
QUEUE UP ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES- ON THE PHONE LINE
WOULD APPRECIATE. AND FOR THOSE
IN OPPOSITION TO THE THIRTEEN
FIFTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION.
MR THIS TIME WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE IN OUR QUEUE ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU FOR CHECKING MODERATOR
WILL BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS BY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. CENTER OF
TROUBLE. I HAVE A- A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS. SO- I'VE BEEN
VISITING MANY OF THE SCHOOLS
LOCALLY- TRAINING CENTERS AND-
SPEAKING JUST DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS WITHIN MY DISTRICT
WITH REGARDS TO TRAINING OUR
YOUTH AND- FOR JOBS MOVING
FORWARD AND SO FORTH. I'M TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND WHY THIS IS
PARTICULARLY NEEDED WHEN WE
ALREADY CURRENTLY HAVE PROGRAMS
IN PLACE THAT ARE TRAINING AND
GIVING OUR STUDENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO COLLABORATE
REGIONALLY WITH LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS WITH REGARDS TO
DIFFERENT EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. WELL YES- THE
BASIC POINT IS THAT WE DON'T
HAVE THE FOCUS AT THE STATE
LEVEL. SO THAT WE CAN-
ADEQUATELY- DISTRIBUTE THE FUNDS
THAT WE DO HAVE FOR WORKFORCE
TRAINING WE'RE NOT REALLY
FOCUSED ON YOUTH AND SO IF IT IF
FUNDS GET OUT THERE INTO YOUTH
PROGRAMS IT'S NOT WITH THE
ORGANIZED WAY OF GETTING THE
FUNDS TO THE YOUTH PROGRAM SO
THAT'S THE MAIN PURPOSE IS THAT%
WE HAVE A STATE LEVEL- YOUTH
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM. THAT
WILL REALLY- FOCUS AND MAKE SURE
THAT FUNDING AND ADEQUATE
FUNDING IS GOING INTO OUR YOUTH
APPRENTICESHIP AND PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS. SO MY
FOLLOW UP QUESTION WOULD BE- HOW
DOES THIS FALL INTO YOUR HOW
DOES IT PLAY WITH IN. PROGRAMS
SUCH AS- THE- R. O. P. TRAINING
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE THEIR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND THE
FUNDING THAT THEY RECEIVE AND
THE WORK THAT THEY'RE ALREADY
DOING WITHIN OUR- WITHIN OUR
DISTRICTS AND- WELL THIS IS NOT
INTENDED TO REPLACE. WHATEVER
PROGRAMS ARE CURRENTLY DOING
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS WITH
YOUTH SANTANDER TO REPLACE THE
MARK TO KNOCK THEM OUT IT'S
INTENDED TO BUILD UPON THEM AND
EXPAND AND GROW- THE NUMBER OF-
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS FOR
YOUTH. OKAY I THINK. THE FEELS
PRESSURE. OKAY ANYBODY ALSO WISH
TO COMMERCENTRE NEWMAN YEAH
THANK YOU MISTER SHOW- SENATOR
RUSSELL. I WANT TO COMMEND YOU
ON THIS BILL- YOU'D BE I'VE I'VE
DONE A LOT OF WORK WITH- ONCE
YOU LOCAL AGENCIES INCLUDING
FOSTER CARE. ADVOCATE AND
THERE'S SAID- THE HEAD OF THE
BROTHERS BIG SISTERS IN MY AREA
IS A GREAT CHIANG AND SINCE YOU
CAN'T BE IT UNLESS YOU SEE IT. I
AND THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT WE
NEEDED CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST PROBLEMS CALIFORNIA WAS
INCOME INEQUALITY- BUT I'D ARGUE
THAT WE ALSO HAVE OPPORTUNITY
AND QUALITY AND WE ARE NOT DOING
A GOOD JOB- CONNECTING YOUNG
PEOPLE. ARE CREATING PATHWAYS TO
THE KINDS OF WORK YOU'VE
DESCRIBED RIGHT TO DUE TO CAREER
OR EMPLOYMENT IN THE TRADES PAGE
WELL CAN'T BE OUTSOURCED- EVEN
AS WE PLACE KIND OF SOMEWHAT
ORGAN UNDUE EMPHASIS ON COLLEGE
DEGREES AND WHITE COLLAR WORK.
ALL RIGHT THIS IS A GOOD AND
VERY LEVERAGE USED TO WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FUNDS ESPECIALLY THE
EARLIER THE BETTER THE SOONER WE
EDUCATE YOUNG PEOPLE- GIVE THEM
A SENSE OF WHAT THEY'RE CAPABLE
OF WHAT THEY MIGHT PURSUE. THE
BETTER THE BETTER THE RETURN ON
THAT INVESTMENT SO MANY ON THE
BILL WOULD BE HONORED TO BE. A
DAD IS A CO. AUTHOR HAPPY TO
MOVE IT TO PROTECT. OKAY ELSE IF
NOT. WE HAVE THE OFFER OF A
MOTION FROM SO NEW CENTER. SO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
AND ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL. OKAY
WITH EMOTION CENTER NEWMAN- WILL
GO AHEAD AS A CONSULTANT CALL
THE ROLL CALL PLEASE. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE FIRST REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COURTESY HI. COURTESY I A CHOI
BOGUE. PROVOKE I'D WRESTLE.
WRESTLE I'D- AYE. LAYERED AYE
NEWMAN. ALL RIGHT NEWMAN AYE.
OKAY THE BILLS OUT ON THE
UNANIMOUS VOTE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. IN THE BY CHAU CHOI BOGAN
MASSEY PER SIDE ONE MORE. TIME
SO I CAN PRESENT MY BILL.
WHAT CONSIDER CORTESE RICHARD
LIKE TO BEGIN WITH SB EIGHT ONE
. YES THEY COULD SURE IN MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT SB THIRTY ONE TWO TODAY
LAST FALL ON OCTOBER TWENTY
FIRST TWENTY TWO ONE OF TALENTED
CINEMATOGRAPHER AUSTRALOID FROM
THE SET OF THE MOVIE RUSS. WHEN
REVOLVER LOADED WITH A LIVE
ROUND WENT OFF KILLING HER AND
INJURING ANOTHER. A MOTHER WAS
TAKEN IN A FAMILY FOREVER
CHANGED SB EIGHT THIRTY ONE
BEGAN AS A RESPONSE TO THE
TRAGEDY ON THE RUSSET. BUT IS OF
ALL THROUGH NUMEROUS DISCUSSIONS
I'VE HAD WITH UNIONS AND GUILDS
REPRESENTING WORKERS IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY. IN THE
GROUND BREAKING LEGISLATION THAT
ADDRESSES A BROADER ISSUE OF
OVERALL HEALTH AND SAFETY. ON
SETS. MAGIC OF FILM AND
TELEVISION CAN OBSCURE THE
DANGERS OF WORKING IN MOTION
PICTURE PRODUCTIONS SHOOTING IS
OFTEN OUTSIDE SUBJECT TO ALL
KINDS OF WEATHER ENTERING
CONDITIONS FOR WORKERS CAN BE
INVOLVED IN ANYTHING FROM
STUNTS. COMPLEX ELECTRICAL SET
UP CAR CRASHES AND EVEN
EXPLOSIONS ALL WHILE WORKING
LONG IRREGULAR HOURS. OTHER
INDUSTRIES ALSO SIGNIFICANT
DANGEROUS SITUATIONS IN THE
WORKPLACE. IF YOU HAVE AS MANY
AND IS VERY THREATS AND ALL IN
ONE PLACE WHERE THE USE OF A
FIREARM. IS JUST PART OF ANOTHER
DAY AT WORK. WE OFTEN HEAR ABOUT
THE TRAGIC INCIDENTS A CO
WORKERS. BUT WE DON'T HEAR ABOUT
THE ACCIDENTS THAT CAUSED
SERIOUS INJURIES AND THE
CONSTANT NEAR MISSES. THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY- THE
INDUSTRYWIDE LABOR MANAGEMENT
SAFETY COMMITTEE DEVELOP SAFETY
BOLTON'S FOR A BROAD ARRAY OF
POTENTIAL HAZARDS INCLUDING THE
USE OF FIREARMS ON SET FOR THAT
THE SHOULD BE COMMENDED AND A
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THE BOLTONS ARE
NOT BY ANY LAWS OR REGULATIONS
THE RECOMMENDED GUIDELINES MANY
RESPONSIBLE PRODUCTIONS FOLLOW
THEM BUT MANY OTHERS A LIP
SERVICE OR AREN'T. BOUND BY THEM
AT ALL. THE ALTERNATE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR SAFETY ON SET
WAS WITH THE EMPLOYER. ACCIDENTS
ARE PREVENTABLE IF SAFETY
MEASURES ARE PRIORITIZE FOLLOWED
AND ENFORCED. ENFORCEMENT AND
LACK THERE OF IS WITH SB THIRTY
ONE ADDRESSES BY TAKING A
PROACTIVE RATHER THAN REACTIVE
APPROACH. SB THIRTY ONE
ESTABLISHES CLEAR ENFORCEABLE
SAFETY STANDARDS PROTECT WORKERS
ON FILM AND TELEVISION
PRODUCTIONS HE RESPECTS THE USE
OF LIVE AMMUNITION ON SET. THAT
MANDATE SUFFICIENT STAFFING OF
QUALIFIED PERSONNEL WITH
FIREARMS ARE ON SET IN REQUIRES
THE ONLY CRUISE WITH SPECIFIC
TRAINING EXPERIENCE AND
QUALIFICATIONS MANAGE FARMS
DURING PRODUCTIONS. MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE BILL RECOGNIZES
ENSURING THE OVERALL HEALTH AND
SAFETY ON SETS REQUIRES ON THE
GROUND OVERSIGHT THIS BILL
REQUIRES EMPLOYERS TO HAVE A
TRAINED QUALIFIED SAFETY
SUPERVISOR ON ALL PRODUCTIONS.
THE CITY SUPERVISOR WILL WILL BE
TASKED WITH CONDUCTING A PRE
PRODUCTION RISK ASSESSMENT. IT
WILL BE ON SITE EVERY DAY TO
ENSURE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
THE CAST CREW AND EVERYONE
INVOLVED IN THE PRODUCTION. THE
CONCEPT OF A CITYSUPERVISOR IS
NOT NEW IN THE END ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY. PRODUCTIONS IN THE UK
AUSTRALIA AND NEW ZEALAND ALL
HAVE SAFETY OFFICER POSITIONS
AND CONSULTING POSITIONS IN BOTH
THE US PRODUCERS IN UNION
MEMBERS WORKING IN THOSE
COUNTRIES ARE FAMILIAR WITH THEM
. THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY
CAME TOGETHER HERE IN CALIFORNIA
SUCCESSFULLY CREATED A COVERT
NINETEEN PLAN. THAT INCLUDED
COMPLIANCE SUPERVISORS. ON EACH
AND EVERY SET. FOCUSED SOLELY A
CODE RELATED HEALTH AND SAFETY
TO ENSURE THE SAFE RETURN TO
WORK DURING THE PANDEMIC. SETS
WERE NEVER THE SOURCE OF
WIDESPREAD. A COVERT INFECTIONS
SO WE KNOW IT'S POSSIBLE TO
PRIORITIZE HEALTH AND SAFETY AND
ALLOCATE THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY. TO MEET THAT
CHALLENGE. SO LONG AS THERE IS A
WILL TO DO IT. BY CODIFYING
PROVEN SAFETY MEASURES CREATED
IN APPROVED BY THE INDUSTRY
STAKEHOLDERS. IN REQUIRING A-
EXCUSE ME IT REQUIRED A CRITICAL
NEW SAFETY POSITION SB EIGHT
THIRTY ONE SETS UP THE FIRST IN
THE NATION REGULATORY STRUCTURE
TO KEEP WORKERS SAFE AND HOLD
EMPLOYERS ACCOUNTABLE. BECAUSE
IT'S UP TO CALIFORNIA THE HOME
OF THE FILM INDUSTRY. THE FILM
INDUSTRY TO SET STRONG STANDARDS
PROTECTIONS SO THAT TRAGIC
ACCIDENTS LIKE WHAT HAPPENED IN
NEW MEXICO. NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN
AS WITH THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY CAN CONTINUE TO THRIVE
THE BILL MOVES US ONE STEP
CLOSER TOWARD THE SCHOOL. LASTLY
MEMBERS I WILL BE TAKING A
MEMBERS TODAY WHICH NUMBER ONE
FURTHER CLARIFY THE ROLE OF THE
SET SAFETY SUPERVISOR. TO
SPECIFY THAT THE ARMOR IS THE
ONLY PERSON WHO CAN HANDLE A
FIREARM. OR HAND A FIREARM TO
THE PERFORMER OR CAST OR CREW.
IN THREE REQUIRE THAT A SAFETY
MEETING TAKE PLACE WHEN FARMS
WILL BE INVOLVED IN THE SCENE.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTY ONE TODAY OR JOHN
LINDLEY THE CALIFORNIA I AT C.
COUNCIL THE POOREST PARTLY FROM
THE DIRECTORS GUILD. OF AMERICA
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CENTER CORTESE- AND WE DO
HAVE. LEAD SUPPORT MISTER JOHN
LINDLEY. ARE YOU ON THE LINE. I
AM PLEASE PROCEED SIR. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOHN LESLIE
AND I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE
INTERNATIONAL CINEMATOGRAPHERS
GUILD IATSE LOCAL SIX HUNDRED WE
REPRESENT TEN THOUSAND MEMBERS
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES. I
MYSELF HAVE BEEN WORKING AS A
CINEMATOGRAPHER ALMOST FORTY
YEARS AND I'M HERE TODAY BECAUSE
I'VE LOST THREE COLLEAGUES TO
AVOIDABLE ACCIDENTS I'VE HAD
MEMBERS DIED BECAUSE THERE WAS
INSUFFICIENT VALUE PLACED ON
KEEPING THEM SAFE. I LOST ONE
MEMBERS ARE JONES TO A TRAIN
TRACK ACCIDENTS ANOTHER BRANCH
RICHMOND TO A CAR ACCIDENT DUE
TO FATIGUE DRIVING AND THE THIRD
HALINA HUTCHINS THE GUNFIRE. AND
EACH TIME I OFFER CONDOLENCES TO
GRIEVING FAMILIES I PROMISE TO
NEVER LET IT HAPPEN AGAIN. AND
IT'S TIME TO DELIVER ON THAT
PROMISE. AND WHILE THESE TRAGIC
DEATHS DREW ATTENTION TO SOME OF
THE DANGERS AND OUR INDUSTRY WE
STILL SUFFER WITH ACCIDENTS AND
NEAR MISSES. WITH EXPLOSIONS CAR
CRASHES AND FATIGUE RELATED
ACCIDENTS THAT COULD HAVE BEEN
AVOIDED WITH GREATER ATTENTION
TO SAFETY. IT'S TIME FOR US TO
STOP BEING REACTIVE AND TO BE
PROACTIVE IN MAKING SAFETY A
PRIORITY AND THAT IS WHY WE ARE
PROUD TO CO SPONSOR S. B. EIGHT
THIRTY ONE. ENTERTAINMENT CENTER
STAFFED BY PROFESSIONALS WHO
CARE DEEPLY ABOUT SAFETY BUT
EACH OF US THE FOCUS NARROWLY ON
OUR OWN CRAFT. BEER ON THE
CAMERA I'M WAITING ON SPEEDING
VEHICLES DEAL WITH FIREARMS
STORAGE AND MORE. WHAT IS
MISSING IS THE PERSON ON SET WHO
IS FOCUSED ENTIRELY ON SAFETY
WHO LOOKS ACROSS ALL THE
DEPARTMENTS AND THE CRAPS. TO
ENSURE THAT ALL WORKERS ARE
SAFE. SB EIGHT THIRTY ONE WOULD
MANDATE A SAFETY SUPERVISOR TO
SERVE AN ESSENTIAL ROLE. THIS
PERSON WOULD BE ON THE GROUND
ALONGSIDE US INSURING SAFETY
PROTOCOLS ARE FOLLOWED IN AN
EVER CHANGING CIRCUMSTANCES.
WHERE QUICK DECISIONS ARE DRIVEN
BY TIGHT BUDGETS AND SCHEDULES.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE
GETTING EACH WORKER HOME SAFELY
IS JUST AS IMPORTANT AS MEETING
PRODUCTION GOALS. AND WHILE THIS
IS A GROUNDBREAKING BILL HERE IS
NOT A NEW CONCEPT I HAVE WORKED
WITH SAFETY SUPERVISORS AT
AUSTRALIA AND THEY'RE ALSO USED
IN NEW ZEALAND IN THE UNITED
KINGDOM. ALL OF OUR MAJOR
EMPLOYERS ALSO OPERATE
SUCCESSFULLY. THEY KNOW HOW TO
COMPLY WITH THE REQUIREMENTS AND
THEY NOTED IT WORKS IN ALL OF
THESE COUNTRIES. THAT TIME FOR
THE INDUSTRY TO SUCCESSFULLY
NAVIGATED A PANDEMIC TO STAND
WITH THOSE OF US WHO WORK SO
HARD TO CREATE THE MAGICAL
MOVIES AND TELEVISION. THE TIME
FOR THEM TO JOIN US IN RAISING
SAFETY STANDARDS AND ENSURING
THERE ARE NO MORE TRAGIC
ACCIDENTS WERE PREVENTABLE
DEATHS. TOGETHER WE CAN EMBRACE
THE NEW RESPECT FOR THE
IMPORTANCE OF. SAFETY AND A NEW
PARTNERSHIP TO MAKE THE SAFETY
PROTOCOLS THAT EXIST ON PAPER
INTO SOMETHING MEANINGFUL AND
REAL. SIMPLY PUT. WE CAN SAVE
LIVES. WE THANK SENATOR CORTESE
PROPER OFFERING THIS IMPORTANT
BILL AND WE ASK. FOR YOUR RIVALS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR LINLEY- WE NOW HAVE
A SET SUPPORT WITNESS. MISTER A
PARIS PARK I'M SORRY. COLLEGE
ICE. MISTER THAT'S FINE THANK
YOU OKAY- GOOD CASEY VICE
CHAIRWOMAN JO BOGAN I WILL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY MY NAME IS PERIS MARC
BERMAN DIRECTOR PAST PRESIDENT
OF DIRECTORS GUILD OF AMERICA
AND CURRENTLY HAVE SERVICE
SECRETARY TREASURER. I'M ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE NATIONAL DJ SAFETY
COMMITTEE. REPRESENTS NINETEEN
THOUSAND DIRECTORS AND MEMBERS
OF THE DIRECTORIAL TEAM
INCLUDING UNIT PRODUCTION
MANAGERS ASSISTANT DIRECTORS
NEARLY EVERY DIRECTOR LOOKS ON
TELEVISION SHOWS YOU SEE AS A DJ
MEMBER AND THEY ALL DESERVE TO
BE SAFE IN THEIR WORKPLACE. I
DIRECTED MANY SHOWS IN THE BOX
STUNTS IN RISKY ACTIVITIES
INCLUDING SONS OF ANARCHY ISSUE
NCIS. LA AND MANY OF. AND IN
EVERY EPISODE. EXPRESSED TO THE
CREW THAT ONE DINNER CAME AS R.
J. IT'S- TO MAKING SURE PERSON.
AT SOME SAFELY TO THEIR FAMILIES
WHO HAVE LOVED ONES AND WE DON'T
WANT ANYONE TO EVEN IMAGINE
KISSING SOMEONE THEY LOVE
GOODBYE IN THE MORNING. WHAT
SHOULD BE A NORMAL DAY. THAT
EVENING THAT THEY WILL NEVER SEE
THEM AGAIN. SO THE TRAGEDY ON
THE SET OF RUST IS ANOTHER WAKE
UP CALL FOR WHY WE NEED MORE
STRINGENT SAFETY PRECAUTIONS ON
SET. AS JOHN AND THEN THE
CHAIRMAN OF CORTEZ'S MENTIONS
CINEMATOGRAPHER ELENA HUTCHINS
DIED. ON HER FAMILY GOT THAT
CALL AND I'M TALKING ABOUT OUR
DIRECTOR. MEMBER CHILLS WHOSE IT
WAS INJURED. RESTAUR THE AND
FIRE BUT IN WORKERS OUR MEMBERS
TO CHURCH. OF STRENGTH LONG AND
DANGEROUS INCIDENTS INVOLVING
CARS HELICOPTERS ELECTRICITY AND
SO ON. THE BRITISH MUSEUM IT'S
CRITICAL THAT THIS LEGISLATION
DEAL WITH FIREARMS BUT ALSO
ADDRESS LARGER STRUCTURAL
ISSUES. BY MANDATING FIFTY
SUPERVISORS AND RISK ASSESSMENT
. PRODUCES OF NOT AS VERIFY NEWS
PER WHEN THERE SHOULD YOU US SO
THERE'S NO REAL THEY SHOULDN'T
THE SAME LAW FIRM CAL. TO KEEP
BERMAN SAY. RECTORS RELY ON AND
WELCOME TRAIN SAFETY
PROFESSIONALS TO GIVE US
LIMITATIONS ON HOW TO FIND
ALTERNATIVE APPROACHES TO KEEP
OUR CRUSADE. WITH PROPER
STAFFING THE CREATIVE TEAM AND
SAFETY PROFESSIONALS CAN WORK
TOGETHER TO ACHIEVE OUR
CREATIVITY. IN A WAY THAT DOES
NOT PUT LIVES AT RISK. YOU CAN
MAKE THIS CALL BEFORE ANY OF THE
OTHER CALLS LIKE THE BIG ONE-
BREAKFAST. NEED TO BE MADE. SO
THANK YOU CHARACTERS YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. WE
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE FOR
THIS LEGISLATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER BARCLAY WILL NOW
BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT THREE ONE
HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. KATHY GARMENTS HE SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT FOR THE ENTERTAINMENT
UNION COALITION. TOM DAVIS
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA TO
SEE COUNCIL SPEAKING IN SUPPORT. SEEN NO OTHER WITNESSES
HEARING TWENTY TWO HUNDRED WILL
NOW CONTINUE AND MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
THE TELECONFERENCE AT SERVICE
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
FROM THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
EIGHT THIRTY ONE WE WILL BEGIN.
HIM FOR THOSE OF YOU IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT THIRTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT THIRTY ONE. AT THIS TIME
WE DO HAVE ABOUT TEN IN OUR
QUEUE. WELL GOODNESS SERVER
NUMBER FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MITCH SNIDER WITH
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
EXPORT. X. TO BE NUMBER TWENTY
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON SHANE
GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COUNCIL COUNCIL AND ALSO
SAG AFTRA IN SUPPORT. THANKS TO
THE NUMBER THIRTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JEREMY
ASSOCIATE NATIONAL EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ART COLLECTORS
SKILLED ATSC LOCAL EIGHT HUNDRED
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT. NUMBER
FORTY SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATORS MY NAME IS BRIDGET
AROUND NOT FIND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE COST CENTER
SKILLED I THE LOCAL EIGHT NINETY
TWO BY LOCAL FULLY SUPPORT SB
EIGHT THIRTY ONE THANK YOU.
NUMBER THIRTY ONE. HELLO MY NAME
IS ADAM WEST IN THE BUSINESS
REPRESENTATIVE OF MOTION PICTURE
CUSTOMERS IATSE LOCAL SEVEN OH
FIVE AND WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NUMBER FIFTY ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS RANDY
SAYER I AM THE BUSINESS
REPRESENTATIVE I GUESS THE LOCAL
SEVEN ZERO SIX AND THE MAKE UP
ARTISTS AND HAIR STYLISTS GUILD
STRONGLY SUPPORTS SB EIGHT
THIRTY ONE THANK YOU. LINE
THIRTY EIGHT. HI GALLAGHER
WRITING FROM THE FLOODED FROM
THE POLITICAL DIRECTOR WITH AND
BE ABLE LOCAL I GOT THE ONE
TWENTY. I'M STRUGGLING SUPPORT
OF SPENDING BILL EIGHT THIRTY
ONE. OKAY. NUMBER. FIFTY THREE.
HELLO JOANNE DESMOND LOCAL
SIXTEEN I NEED TO GET THE IN SAN
FRANCISCO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NUMBER FIFTY TWO. HELLO MY NAME
IS TO BE BASED ON THE VISITATION
OF LOCAL FORTY FOUR THE
AFFILIATED PROPERTY CRAP LOS
ANGELES I REPRESENT OVER SEVEN
THOUSAND CRAFTS PERSONS
INCLUDING PROP MASTERS THAT
PERFORM THE WORK OF OUR MEMBERS
I'M IN FULL SUPPORT SB. EIGHT
THIRTY ONE. ONE FIFTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ROBERT BACK
NADA I AM THE BUSINESS
REPRESENTATIVE FOR IATSE LOCAL
THIRTY THREE LIVE ENTERTAINMENT
STAGE HANDS AND I AM VERY MUCH
IN SUPPORT. OF S. B. EIGHT
THIRTY ONE. LINE. FIFTY FIVE.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
FEDERATION OF LABOR COUNTERPART. THE MANAGER AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER MOTOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE CHECK THE
LIGHTS ONE MORE TIME JUST TO
REST ASSURE THAT WE HAVE HEARD
FROM ALL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
SB EIGHT THIRTY ONE. ABSOLUTELY
HOW ONCE AGAIN ON THE PHONE
LINES IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. EIGHT THIRTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. THE AN ONE ZERO
FOUR SUPPORT. WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE IN OUR QUEUE. IT WILL GO TO
NUMBER FIFTY SIX. BUT MANY OF
KARLSKRONA CALLING FROM LOCAL
ONE TWENTY TWO AND SAN DIEGO THE
ICC I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT. AT
THE TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN
OUR QUEUE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MODERATOR- LET'S HAVING HEARD
FROM ALL OF OUR SUPPORTERS WILL
NOW FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION LET'S
MOVE TO ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. SEEING
NONE THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES WILLING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
FROM THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO. OF S.
B. EIGHT THIRTY ONE WE WILL
BEGIN. NUMBER DISTANCE ON THE
PHONE LINES APPEAR IN OPPOSITION
TO IT S. B. EIGHT THIRTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. GOOD ONE
ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. AT THIS
TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE IN
OUR QUEUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER MARKER IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE CHECK THE LINES ONE MORE
TIME JUST RESEARCH FOR THAT WE
HAVE HEARD FROM ANY- ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
EIGHT THIRTY ONE. ABSOLUTELY
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT THIRTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. IN
ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. AT THE
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE IN OUR QUEUE
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MODERATOR AND THANK YOU TO ALL
OUR SUPPORT IN OFFICE WELL IF WE
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES
VERY. HAVING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO REMEMBERS. AN AGREEMENT THANK
YOU MEASURE- CHAU SHOWED AS IT
HAPPENS- I'M ACTUALLY I THINK
I'M THE ONLY MEMBER THE
LEGISLATURES OF FORMER MEMBER OF
IT- LOCAL FORTY FOUR- AND- YOU
KNOW PLEASED TO HEAR. A WHOLE
BUNCH OF FOLKS WHEN UNITS
SUPPORT I WAS I WAS MOVED BY MR
LINDLEY'S REFERENCE TO THE
SYRIAN JONES. RAJIDAE THERE WAS
AND GEORGE IN TWENTY FOURTEEN ON
THE SET OF MIDNIGHT RIDER- I
ACTUALLY A FRIEND AND FORMER
COLLEAGUE WHO WAS PART OF THAT-
WHO ACTUALLY WANT TO PLEAD
GUILTY TO A FELONY INVOLUNTARY
MANSLAUGHTER- AND I PROMISE YOU
NOT A SINGLE DAY GOES BY WHERE
HE DOESN'T REGRET- HAVE YOU BEEN
MORE THOROUGH BUT DOCTOR I THINK
WOULD HAVE BEEN GRATEFUL- AND
BENEFITTED GREATLY FROM HAVING.
AN ONSET SAFETY SUPERVISOR SO-
IN PASSING THIS BILL AND I'M
GOING TO BE A CO AUTHOR THIS
BILL I THINK WE CAN PREVENT
THAT. FROM EVER HAPPENING
CALIFORNIAN I COMMEND YOU CENTER
GORGEOUS BRING THIS LEGISLATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTER EVEN. TO ANY OF OUR OTHER
MEMBERS. HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OKAY- I JUST HAD A
QUESTION- SENATOR CORTESE NOT
WAS WITH REGARDS TO THE- I
UNDERSTAND THAT HERE IT WAS
READING IN MY NOTES THAT-
THERE'S THE PENALTIES THAT ARE
BEING ASSESSED- IN CASE OF A
VIOLATION AND I WAS WONDERING.
AND I'M NOT SURE HOW THIS WOULD
WORK IN THIS ENVIRONMENT BUT IS
THERE ARE- RIGHT TO CURE. THE
PERIOD OF TIME WHERE PEOPLE
COULD FIX THINGS OR THEY
AUTOMATICALLY GIVEN THE- THE
PENALTIES ASSESSED HERE- YOU
KNOW WE HAVE TURNED OVER IN THE
BILL- THE WORK TO PROMULGATE THE
ACTUAL REGULATIONS THAT WOULD
THAT WOULD TRIGGER CODE
ENFORCEMENT VIOLATIONS- TO CAL
OSHA. BUT I'M HAPPY AS WE GO
FORWARD TO- TO GET MORE CLARITY
ON THAT TO REPORT BACK TO YOUR
OFFICE DIRECTLY BUT ALSO TO MAKE
SURE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
LEGISLATURE WANTS TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND- WHAT THE COMPLIANCE
PROCESS WOULD WOULD LOOK LIKE
WITH- AN OSHA OFFICER SHOWS UP
ON THE SET. WHO TYPICALLY WITH
CODE ENFORCEMENT VIOLATIONS OF
THAT NATURE OF ANY NATURE IN THE
IN THE WORKFORCE- THERE'S A
COMPLIANCE ORDER THIS IS
CORRECT. OR ELSE YOU'LL BE FINE
WE'LL GET CLARITY ON THAT REPORT
BACK TO YOU. IT'S A VERY MUCH I
THINK ONE OF THE MAJOR CONCERNS
THAT I HAVE RIGHT NOW IS THAT WE
SCARE OFF THE- MOVIE INDUSTRY.
OUTSIDE OF THE STATE SO WHEN WE
HAVE FINES THAT CAN BE EXTREMELY
EXPENSIVE AND WE DON'T KNOW YOU
KNOW HOW PROBLEMATIC THEY WOULD
BE I MEAN I DON'T KNOW- BUT I
JUST I ALWAYS LIKE TO. GIVE
EVERYONE AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE
ABLE TO- ADDRESS AN ISSUE OR A
CONCERN PRIOR TO BEING YOU KNOW
FINAL. PENALIZE BASICALLY
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
FINANCIAL- OPPORTUNITIES BUT I
THINK SAFETY IS OF THE UTMOST
CONCERN AND THE OTHER QUESTION I
HAVE- IN YOUR OPINION THERE'S
ANOTHER BILL THAT WE SUPPORTED.
THAT I SUPPORTED AN ANSWER I
THINK WE ALL DID- WITH SENATOR
PORTANTINO'S BILL- HOW WOULD YOU
. SORT OF COMPARE YOUR BILL WITH
WITH HIS BILL. I THINK THE MAIN
OF WAR ONE OF THE MAIN
DIFFERENCES AND I HAVEN'T- I
HAVEN'T HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
THE COMMITTEE TO NOTE TO
FORMALLY REVIEW THAT BILL BUT-
THE SURNAME QUITE AWARE OF IT.
IN CENTER PORTUNE I'VE TALKED
MANY TIMES- GOING BACK TO LAST
FALL- IS STARTING THE- STARTING
SOON AFTER THE REST TRAGEDY- TO
MY KNOWLEDGE. HAVEN'T NOT SEEN
THAT THE PRINT COPIES BILL YOU
KNOW IN THE LAST FEW DAYS IT
DOES NOT HAVE THE SAFETY
SUPERVISOR. OF RIGHT IN IT FOR
OVER ALL CTC YOU HEARD SOME OF
THE TESTIMONY TODAY TALKING
ABOUT YES WE- WE WANT TO CODIFY
WE MEAN THE WITNESSES WE WANT TO
CODIFY THE BEST PRACTICES THAT
ARE IN THE BALTICS BOLTON ONE
INTO- WERE BASICALLY THE
UNIONIZED INDUSTRY AND- THE
PORTION OF THE- MOTION PICTURE
ASSOCIATION THAT'S THAT'S- TIED
TO THOSE BOLTON'S. ABIDES BY
CERTAIN SAFETY STANDARDS ON A ON
A CONTRACTUAL BASIS ONE WE ARE
SAYING THOUGH SHOULD BE
CODIFIED. I'M NOT SURE OF HIS
HIS BILL DOES THAT OR NOT THAT'S
VERY IMPORTANT ON THE FARM SIDE
BUT YOU HEARD WITNESSES TODAY
YOU SAY THERE ARE. LOTS AND LOTS
OF OTHER SAFETY. ISSUES ON SETS
THAT- WE BELIEVE REQUIRE. OF AN
OVERALL INDEPENDENT CD
SUPERVISOR TO HELP PUT TOGETHER
THE SAFETY PLAN IN ADVANCE OF.
THE PRODUCTION ON THE SET IT AND
THEN HOLDS FOLKS ACCOUNTABLE NOT
OCEAN AT THIS POINT BUT SAFETY
SUPERVISOR. OF FUNCTIONING AS-
OF THE- NO OF ALLIGATOR OF THOSE
SAFE PRACTICES ON THE SET IN
MAKING SURE THAT WHATEVER PLAN
THEY PUT PLACES ACTUALLY BEING
INVITED BY. THAT THAT IS IN THIS
BILL AND I DON'T BELIEVE IT'S IN
THE BILL. PERFECT THANK YOU
SENATOR CORTESE- TO THE SENATOR
TORONTO YES THANK YOU I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHORS WELL IN ALL
THE SUPPORTERS THIS IS A LIFE
AND DEATH ANNA AT TO HEAR OF ANY
ONE TWO OR THREE NO MATTER WHAT
MAY APPEAR TO BE A SMALL NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE DIED. WE'VE
GOTTEN KILLED ON IN THIS LINE OF
WORK I THINK MOST PEOPLE WOULD
BE VERY SHOCKED TO HEAR THAT AND
HAVE BEEN ON THE GROUND IN REAL
TIME THEIR ADDRESS SEEMS OF
SAFETY ISSUES I THINK IS GREAT
AND I COULD SEE NO OPPOSITION TO
THIS SO I ASSUME. THAT THERE IS
THERE IS AGREEMENT AND I KNOW
AND IMPRENTA CEASE BUT THERE'S
AGREEMENT THAT THIS ISSUE NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED AND ALL ARE
WILLING PARTICIPANTS IN THIS SO
I COMMEND YOU AND ALL THE- ALL
THE SUPPORTERS FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR DRAWS SO. ANYONE ELSE.
CAN DO HAVE A MOTION ON THIS
BILL. OKAY PERFECT SAID AS WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR NEWMAN
ACIDITY PARTIES WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU FOR THE
DISCUSSION OF IN A RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
N. THE BILL HAS REMOVED A CENTER
COURT. NEWMAN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST THE MEN AND WE
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
AND JUDICIARY CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. YES THE MOTION IS
DEPRESSED BUT FIRST AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY COURTESY. COURTESY I-
CHOI BOGUE HI THE TROUBLED BY
THE RUSSELL. THE WRESTLE I'D
LAYERED. THERE AYE NEWMAN NEWMAN
AYE. FIVE ZERO AND THE- BILL
PASSES FIVE TWO ZERO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CONGRATULATIONS
SENATOR PER TASTE.
THANK YOU YOUR MEMBERS SURE OF
FOR PRESIDING- WE NEED TO GO
BACK IN- WITH THE CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS AND ALSO CONSOLE
TO THAT THIS TIME. FOR ITEM SIX
SB NINE FIVE SEVEN OR CHOI BOGUE
. THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
FIRST REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY A TROUBLED. NINE
FIVE SEVEN NINE FIVE SEVEN SORRY
. THE NEWMAN ALL RIGHT NEWMAN I.
NO BUT TROUBLED NO. THAT'S FORTY
ONE OKAY THE BILLS OUT ON A FOUR
TO ONE VOTE. IN THE PLEASE
CONTINUE TO HOLD. FOR THIS IS A
MUSIC IN TIME TO MISS NOTHING
WELCOME TO SAY THAT WILL TAKE
THAT THE WRONG WAY COLLEAGUES AT
. THE BILL WITHOUT WITHOUT IT
WITHOUT A- WITH THAT A- WHAT A
SECOND NEGATIVE A POINT OF ORDER
R. A. U. S. I HAVE A POINT OF
ORDER YES RECEIVE SAYS SOMEBODY
WISHES. THOUGHT THAT MAYBE SHE
DIDN'T VOTE CORRECTLY AND WOULD
LIKE TO RECONSIDER VOTE TWICE TO
MOVE RECONSIDERATION OF THE
ITEM- I DON'T I'M I'M NOT ENOUGH
OF A PARLIAMENTARIAN TO KNOW THE
ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION BUT IT I
BELIEVE UNDER ROBERT'S RULES IF
YOU MOVE RECONSIDERATION AND TRY
TO. GRASP DEFEAT FROM THE JAWS
OF VICTORY CARDS FOR A IT WOULD
BE FIVE OH RATHER THAN FOR ONE
BUT I NEED TO BILLS THAT WOULD
ALLOW IT OUT IT IF YOU MOVE
RECONSIDERATION WELL WE'RE STILL
CONVENE WE HAVEN'T DURING THE
MEETING. THEN I WOULD MOVE
RECONSIDERATION OF FILE ITEM SIX
S. B. NINE FIFTIES. OKAY AND I'M
JUST GONNA ASK THE CONSULTANT I
THINK WE HANDLE IT THIS WAY TO
TAKE THE ROLL CALL IF THERE'S
ANY- FURTHER. IF THERE'S AN- WE-
ADVERTISEMENT NUMBER ONE. BUT I
WAS GOING TO SUGGEST IS THAT
YOU'LL HAVE YOU HAVE THE ONE
ROLL CALL VOTE. IF THE MOTION
FOR RECONSIDERATION ISN'T DEEMED
LATER AS OUT OF ORDER CENTER
WHERE WE USE WE USE I WOULD
ACCEPT THE FACT THAT IT WAS OUT
OF ORDER WE GO BACK TO THE
ORIGINAL ROLL CALL SO WE SHOULD
HAVE THE TO ROLL CALLS ON THE
RECORD- THAT MAKES SENSE. YOU
HAVE HOW LONG WOULD IT TAKE HOW
LONG IS IT GOING TO TAKE YOU TO
FIND OUT.
NUMBERS WERE PERFECT I'M GONNA
SUGGESTED IT TOO WE HAVE- ON A
MOTION FOR RECONSIDERATION. ON
THE RECONSIDERING RYAN RIGHT AND
NOW MOVES THE BILL AGAIN.
ANOTHER NIGHT YES YES THAT
SOUNDS RIGHT SO THEN THE VOTE IS%
FOR THE RECONSIDERATION- CENTER
COURTESY HI I OR TWO AGO. I
WRESTLE I'D LAYERED HI HI NEWMAN
I RECONSIDERATION GRANTED I KNOW
THAT THIS IS REALLY SELF SERVING
BUT- I WOULD MOVE ITEM NUMBER
SIX. YOU CAN'T SENATOR NEWMAN
JUST MOVED TO IAGO I THANK
SENATOR NEWMAN FOR THE CENTER
NEWMAN MOVE THE BILL UNDER
CONSIDERATION. M. FOR SO TO PASS
FIRST REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY CORTES C. HI I A
CHOI BOGUE I THE REST SO. AYE
LAYERED AYE AYE NEWMAN. THAT'S A
THREE FORCE I. WOULD HAVE BEEN
INTERESTING IF EVERYONE VOTED NO
YES- WITH WITHOUT THE BILL- IN
THE BILL ON THE MOTION FOR
RECONSIDERATION IS OUT FIVE ZERO
AGAIN LET THE RECORD SHOW THAT
PRIOR TO RECONSIDERATION IT WAS
OUT ON A FOUR TO ONE VOTE AND-
SHOULD THERE BE ANY FURTHER-
THE- ARBITRATION IF YOU WILL OF
THE PARLIAMENTARY PROCEDURE-
THIS COMMITTEE DIFFERS- A TO THE
DESK ON WHICH OF THOSE ROLL CALL
VOTES- WILL BE FINE. OKAY AND-
THANK YOU EVERYONE- I THINK
COMMITTEE STAFF- IN THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALL YOUR USUAL
EFFORTS TODAY AND THANKS TO ALL
THE WITNESSES. WHO SHOWED UP
TODAY AND TESTIFY THANK YOU. WE
ARE JOURNAL.